Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist die 199. Ausgabe dieser Serie. Und ja, nach einer längeren Winterpause rollt der Zug mal wieder voran. Und ich hab mir auch was Schönes ausgedacht, um hier das Programm wieder ein bisschen aufzunehmen und möchte mal ein wenig in eine ganz spezielle Vergangenheit eintauchen, die für meinen Geschmack zu wenig wahrgenommen wird. Und deswegen muss da ein wenig drauf geschaut werden. Konkret geht es um NetHack und was sich hinter diesem Begriff Schönes verbirgt, das erzählt uns hier gleich der Felix, Felix Vogel, hallo.
Hallo Tim.
Ja, schön, schön, dass das mal geklappt hat.
Ich freue mich auch.
Und ich finde, jetzt ist aber auch echt genau der richtige Zeitpunkt gekommen. Tja, Felix, du bist ja auch so ein, was bist du für ein Baujahr eigentlich?
71.
71, ok, dann liegen wir ja so etwa in der gleichen Abteilung, genau, in der gleichen Liga.
Richtig.
Und wann bist du so in den Computer-Zaubertopf gefallen?
Ich glaube, ich bin da relativ zeitig reingefallen durch meinen Vater, der ja im Wissenschaftsbetrieb unterwegs war und immer wenn wir den besucht haben im Institut, gab es da schon die Möglichkeit mit so Terminals im Kindesalter von einer Etage zu anderen zu chatten.
Von welchem Zeitraum reden wir jetzt?
Na, das muss in den späten 70ern gewesen sein, wo ich das so wahrgenommen habe. Und es gab dann auch schon früh Homecomputer selber, ZX81 zu Hause gelötet und solche Geschichten.
Wie gelötet? Du hast ihn gelötet?
Mein Vater hat ihn gelötet. Wieso? Als Bausatz. Den gab es als Bausatz? Und es gab auch die 16K-Speicherarbeitung als Bausatz, die allerdings leider nie funktioniert hat.
Aber der hat auch sowieso kaum was gekostet.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum. Ich glaube, das war...
Er wollte einfach.
Ich denke, ja, da war die Challenge. Die Speicherarbeitung hat nie funktioniert.
Also dein Vater war ein Nerd.
Vielleicht. Ja, irgendetwas.
Oder ein Hacker.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob er so ein krasser Nerd gewesen ist, aber er war auf jeden Fall technikaffin.
Ja, der Sinclair ZX81, das hat sicherlich hier auch schon ein paar Mal gefallen, ist so ein absurder Computer gewesen. Also auch nach heutigen Maßstäben finde ich den irgendwie total absurd. Weil der war so konsequent auf, ich muss billig sein.
Ja, es erinnert ein bisschen an den Taschenrechner. Oder auch mit dieser Folientastatur. Und alle Basic-Befehle waren auf der Folientastatur. Es gab da irgendwie auf jeder Taste drei oder vier Kommandos. Es war tatsächlich ein absurder Computer.
Ja, und so komische Grafik-Symbole, die man noch eingeben konnte.
Genau, und dann konnte man in Basic kleine Programme schreiben, wo man dann schon richtig mit Grafik...
Ich kam dann mal so auch in meinem jugendlichen Leichtsinn auf die Idee, da mal so ein tolles Labyrinth zu bauen und war dann halt irgendwie der Meinung, man müsste dann halt ja nur möglichst viele Print-Anweisungen machen, die so ein Labyrinth malen, da würde man schon hinkommen. Und bin natürlich dann erstaunlich schnell an die Grenze von einem Kino bei uns gekommen.
Das war eine Kunst, da was zu programmieren.
Ja, und da hat mir dann irgendwie überhaupt erst mal so diesen Respekt eingeflößt vor Speicher-Ressourcenknappheit. Also das waren so interessante Einblicke. Ansonsten habe ich mich nicht zu sehr mit der Maschine beschäftigt, aber selber zusammenlöten. Warst du dann dabei?
Ich habe da interessiert zugeguckt, ja, aber das war natürlich auch, sag mal mal, beyond my sphere. Das war etwas mit Interesse verfolgt, sagen wir mal so, ja.
Okay, aber du bist dann schon mal sozusagen in der ersten Zeremonie?
Ja, das ging ziemlich früh los, tatsächlich. Das ging tatsächlich ziemlich früh los, genau.
Und wann wurde es dann ernst?
Ernst wurde das. Ich habe dann nach der Schule lange Zeit erstmal gar nichts gemacht und dann hat mein Vater Mitleid mit mir gehabt und mir einen Computer geschenkt. Dann hatte ich irgendwie... Einen was? Das war damals ein PC. Und da gab es MS-DOS drauf mit Windows 3.11 und das war frustrierend. Und dann habe ich angefangen, mich für das alternative Betriebssystem, was damals ja gerade rauskam, zu interessieren.
Also Linux Anfang der 90er Jahre, 1992.
Genau, noch in der Buchhandlung irgendwie, so Suse Linux in der Buchhandlung gekauft und installiert. Und von da ist tatsächlich so eine Leidenschaft rausgeworden, dass ich dann auch mich an der Uni eingeschrieben habe und habe das nicht zu Ende gemacht. Das gehört ja hier zum guten Ton, habe ich gehört.
Eine Auszeichnung.
Genau, und bin dann aber als ich darunter war, habe ich dann angefangen, einfach auch zu arbeiten in dem aufkommenden IT-Business, was ja irgendwie dankbar alle Leute an sich gezogen hat. Und bin ja auch bis jetzt dabei geblieben und mache jetzt so, was man neudeutsch Operations nennt, also so Planung und Betrieb von IT-Systemen, also eigentlich Web-Applikationen für eine Berliner Firma, die so im Suchbusiness waren, kann man fast sagen. Aber ich mache das eigentlich immer noch ganz gerne. Also ich bin drangeblieben.
Drangeblieben. Aber du gehörst ja auch so zum Seabase-Universum, kann man sagen. Warst du eigentlich auch ganz früh dabei, oder?
Ja, nicht ganz bei der Gründung, aber ich denke, es muss im Laufe des ersten Jahres irgendwie passiert sein. Und ich glaube, das ist auch die Schiene, wo wir uns dann irgendwann...
Damals, als die Seabase noch am Hackschenmarkt war.
Richtig, genau.
Wenn ich weiß, wovon wir reden, die Seabase ist so eine Art Weltraum-Ausgrabungsstätte in Berlin. Ein Verein, der sich die Erforschung der Seabase, einer von Millionen Jahren abgestürzten Raumstationen, so eigen gemacht hat. Und dieser erste Ort war ja sozusagen direkt dran. Da wurden ja sozusagen auch unmittelbar Sachen gefunden worden. Mittlerweile hat man sich so ein bisschen mehr nach draußen verlagert.
Naja, aber ja, stimmt.
Abgestürzte Module, die vorher schon irgendwo in die da geschlagen sind, sind angriffgenommen. Heute nebenbei dann auch noch ein schöner Treffpunkt und vor allem auch so ein Sammelpunkt von Wahnsinnigen. Und, und deswegen erwähne ich das jetzt eigentlich auch, Seabase ist auch für mich immer so ein Ort gewesen, wo Spieler aller Art eigentlich ganz gut zusammengefunden haben. Aber nicht jetzt so sehr so diese Counter-Strike-Zockernummer, das sicherlich auch mal in der einen oder anderen Ecke lief, sondern das Fantastische, hat eigentlich da immer schon seinen Raum gehabt und Worms natürlich.
Und Worms, ja genau. Salunothek, es gab schon viel so Retro-Game-Treffen und so was. Also tatsächlich gibt es da, vielleicht liegt das auch an dem relativ voren Altersdurchschnitt, dass da viel so Retro-Gaming stattfindet, stattgefunden hat. Auf jeden Fall wird viel gespielt, das stimmt. Und wir hatten auch mal eine schöne NetHack-Installation, aber ich glaube, die wird nicht mehr benutzt. Aber dazu vielleicht später.
Na, vielleicht ändert sich das ja jetzt. NetHack, jetzt haben wir es schon zweimal gesagt, wir wollen hier mal ein wenig die Historie eines ganz speziellen Spiels ergründen, was mal auch ein unglaubliches Alleinstellungsmerkmal hatte und damit eigentlich auch nie verlieren wird. NetHack ist ein ganz spezielles Game, im Prinzip ein Rollenspiel-Game. Rollenspiele waren ja hier auch schon mal ein Thema in CRE 173. Da haben wir das mal so ein bisschen beleuchtet, aber da ging es halt sozusagen um die richtigen Rollenspiele, also, was heißt die richtigen Rollenspiele?
Pen-and-Paper, würde man sagen.
Genau, Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspiele, also wo man halt am Tisch sitzt und im sozialen Miteinander ohne Computer als Hilfsmitte, ohne zumindest, dass sie erforderlich wären.
Ja, da gab es doch manchmal auch so längliche Tabellen und komplizierte Regeln, dass das manchmal hilfreich gewesen wäre.
sicherlich auch im heutigen Spielbetrieb auch elektronische Geräte, also gerade hier, was weiß ich, so iPads oder so was, kann ich mir da ganz gut vorstellen. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch schon längs Realität, ich weiß es bloß nicht, weil ich bin ja nicht so ein Spieltyp, aber NetHack bin ich auch mal hängen geblieben, zumindest für eine gewisse Zeit, aber ich habe da immer nicht so die Energie gehabt, das alles zu durchdringen. Trotzdem, und war es halt auch ein Spiel der sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr frühen Zeit, weil wir gehen jetzt nämlich im Prinzip schon wieder zurück in die 18er.
Ja, genau, also der Ursprung, man sagt auch, also es gibt ein eigenes Genre, in dem das NetHack angehört, das sogenannte Roguelike spielen. Das ist so ein Genre, muss man sich vorstellen, wie Jump'n'Run oder vielleicht ein Ego-Shooter oder sowas. Das hat also sozusagen sein, also wenn man sagen würde, Doom ist die Mutter aller Ego-Shooter, dann würde man sagen Rogue ist die Mutter aller Roguelike Games, also aller dieser Spiele, die diese Eigenschaften haben.
Ist das wirklich die einzige mögliche Bezeichnung Roguelike? Ist jetzt nicht so ein Computer-Role-Playing-Game, trifft es nicht so?
Doch, trifft es genau. Roguelike würde ich sagen, hat noch ein paar mehr Eigenschaften, aber ich denke mal auch, das ist schon ein sehr spezielles Genre, weil selbst als ich jetzt hier mal geforscht habe, so viele Spiele, die diesem Genre jetzt konkret angehören, prinzipiell konkret gibt es dann auch nicht. Eine gute Handvoll habe ich gefunden, die sich sozusagen aus diesem Rogue heraus destilliert haben. Im Prinzip sind das alles Forks von dieser sehr frühen Version, die in den 80er Jahren, ich glaube in der Berkeley-Universität von zwei Studenten entwickelt wurde, die mit Sicherheit große Pen-and-Paper-Rollenspieler waren und gleichzeitig vor der Aufgabe standen, etwas mit einer neuen Computerbibliothek machen zu müssen, die Curses hieß, mit der man Folgendes tun konnte. Man konnte nicht nur Text, was natürlich logischerweise schon immer ging, einfach fließenden Text auf dem Bildschirm darstellen, sondern man konnte den Cursor positionieren an einer beliebigen Stelle und Zeichen an einer beliebigen Stelle auf dem Bildschirm. Also es waren ja einfache Terminals mit 80 x 25 Zeichen positionieren und darüber eben neue Möglichkeiten erforschen, nämlich quasi solche Dinge wie Bilder oder eben jenseits von Text versuchen darzustellen.
Also User-Interfaces vielleicht später dann, aber am Anfang waren es vor allem so Labyrinthe und überhaupt mal die Möglichkeit, so eine Liste auf dem Bildschirm zu zaubern.
Genau, oder Menüs und sowas wie Highlighter-Menüs und da Auswahl drüber zu machen. Ich glaube, man konnte auch sowas wie kleine Fenster definieren innerhalb des Terminals, die dann wieder separat für sich bespielt werden konnten und solche Geschichten.
Das war echt eine Revolution. Man muss jetzt nochmal klarmachen, dass in den 80er-Jahren der Standardzugang zum Rechner war halt das Terminal. Mit DOS hat sich das dann schon so ein bisschen geändert, weil bei DOS kam sozusagen dieses Prinzip auf, dass die Programme dann einfach direkt da im Bildschirm herum, also im Bildschirm in den Videokarten herumgeschrieben haben, aber vorher und eben auch lange, lange Zeit, vor allem in der UNIX-Welt, war es ja, wobei es bei UNIX ja teilweise heute noch so ist, der Zugang zum Rechner war halt das Terminal, also im Prinzip ein Rechner jenseits des Computers, der eigentlich nur über irgendeine serielle Verbindungskommunikation da mit dem Hauptsystem kommunizierte und über dieses einfache Hin und Her von Tasten drücken und einzelnen Zeichen, die ausgegeben werden musse, hatte man dann nur eben nur die Möglichkeit, über diese Escape-Sequenzen sozusagen out of band zu sagen, ja jetzt mal mal nicht dieses Zeichen, sondern tu mal was besonderes, klingel mal, mach bunt, vielleicht wahrscheinlich nicht mal bunt. Am Anfang auch nicht bunt, nein, aber so Bildschirm löschen hat sich früh durchgesetzt, das war ganz hilfreich. Aber so Kleinkram und dann irgendwann eben auch setzt man den Cursor an eine bestimmte Stelle, weil die ersten Terminals hatten ja noch nicht mal Bildschirme, sondern die ersten Terminals waren Drucker und dass man überhaupt mehrere Zeilen gleichzeitig sehen konnte, war ja dann schon eher eine Errungenschaft der Neuzeit.
Ja, aber das hatten die Jungs schon, glaube ich.
Jetzt sind wir schon richtig im Oper erzählt vom Kriegmodus, da gehört NetHack definitiv auch mit rein.
Genau, also was die auch noch getrieben hat war sicher...
Wieso hieß das eigentlich Curses, diese Bibliothek? Flüche.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht. Das kann ich hier nicht sagen, warum das Curses heißt. Das heißt ja auch nicht Curser oder irgendwas, sondern wo dir da eine große Rolle spielt.
Wahrscheinlich ist es von Curser abgeleitet, so als Witz.
Das könnte sein, aber ich habe da leider keine Antwort auf die Frage. Fragen Sie mal. Korakel.
Das hätte man schon vor 20 Jahren mal fragen sollen. Damals hat man das einfach noch so mitgenommen.
Genau, aber was es damals auch schon gab, waren so Text-Adventure, also dass so Abenteuerspiele am Bildschirm stattfanden mit Fleece-Text, dass man praktisch die Abenteuergeschichte durchlebt hat, indem man halt Text bekommen hat, der bestimmte Situationen beschrieben hat und dann in so Pseudo-englischen Satzbau mit dem Spiel interagieren konnte. Da konnte man dann halt sowas sagen wie Take Hammer oder Hit Monster with Hammer on Head oder so was oder X, Z, M, N, X, Y. Du bist jetzt noch bei Rogue. Ich bin noch bei Rogue und ich glaube, was die Motivation war von denen oder was sie auch gesagt haben, sie wollten nämlich auch ein, sie hatten sich dann entschieden ein Abenteuerspiel zu machen mit dieser N-Kursus-Bibliothek.
Also Rogue war sozusagen auch schon grafisch in Anführungsstrichen.
Das war der große und genau, das war der Anwendungsfall für diese Bibliothek. Es gab nicht nur Fleece-Text, wo man sozusagen wie in einem Chat, in einem Dialog mit dem Programm standen konnte.
Früher waren die Text-Adventures eigentlich alle, dass man wie so auf einer Kommandozeile immer mit dem System kommuniziert hatte. Hier Look Room und so weiter.
Also ich versuche so ein bisschen zu erklären, was auch dieses Rogue-like ausmacht. Also das ist sicherlich eine, also diese Cursus-Geschichte, dass diese Art der Darstellung, was da genau dargestellt wird, komme ich gleich zu. Das ist sicherlich ein Alleinstellungsmarkmal. Und das sind auch alles eigentlich Abenteuer, Rollenspiel-Abenteuerspiele, wollte ich auch sagen, was sie alle gemeinsam haben. Und was eben bei diesen Text-Adventures auch ein Problem war, derjenige, der das Adventure geschrieben hatte, hatte halt keine Möglichkeit daran Spaß zu haben, weil er natürlich die Lösung, und das natürlich kannte, also sozusagen nicht selber sein Spiel spielen konnte.
Weil die meistens einfach mehr so fragebogenartiges Design hatten.
Eine Lösung sozusagen. Oder vielleicht...
Die einen den richtigen Ort und finde das richtige Ding, und dann kannst du da wieder was machen.
Also die Idee war halt, ein Spiel auch zu schreiben, in dem auch der Entwickler selber Spaß hat. Genau. Das er spielen kann. Und ich glaube, das haben sie halt erreicht, indem sie sehr viele Dinge mit Zufällen gemacht haben. Und auch das Spiel sich jedes Mal neu initialisiert mit Synonymen, also für bestimmte Gegenstände, die man dann neu erforschen und erkennen muss. Also es ist sozusagen sehr wenig langweilig dadurch. Also man hat nie dasselbe Spiel, kann man sagen. Das ist sozusagen eine Sache. Und es gibt noch was, was ich gefunden habe, was auch sicher ein Alleinstangsmerkmal ist, der sogenannte Permadeath. Das bedeutet, dass man das Spiel zwar abspeichern kann, aber wenn man es wieder aufnimmt, der Spielstand gelöscht wird, man also in einem Zug durchspielen muss. Man hat nicht die Möglichkeit...
Man ist so richtig tot.
Genau. Man ist permanent. Permadeath.
Das ist halt wieder groß im Kommen.
Okay, also das ist natürlich in gewisser Weise reizvoll, aber kann auch frustrierend sein. Aber das ist sicherlich die Sache. Also man stirbt und stirbt und dann geht das wieder von vorne los und dann sind auch alle Erkenntnisse, über die man immer das Spiel gewonnen hat, bis dahin natürlich verloren, weil es sich wieder neu initialisiert und man von vorne anfängt. Und das sind so auf jeden Fall Punkte, die diese Spiele alle gemeinsam haben und das Rogue war eben genau der Anfang davon. Und ich habe auch noch eine interessante Sache bei der Recherche zu der Sendung gefunden, die ich auch nicht wusste und zwar bei UNIX ist es ja ziemlich einfach, Ein- und Ausgabe umzulenken und es gab dann Leute, die ziemlich früh angefangen haben, dieses Rogue-Spiel nicht selbst zu spielen, sondern Programme zu schreiben, die das spielen.
Ah, Bots sozusagen.
Genau. Das waren sozusagen die ersten Bots. Und es gab auch tatsächlich damals dann schon ernsthafte, es war ja auch im universitären Kontext, Anwendung, zumindest sagt das die Wikipedia, dass da solche Geschichten wie so Experten-Systeme daran erforscht wurden. Und es gibt auch die Geschichte, dass die Herren Entwickler bei jedem neuen Release versucht haben, den so zu bauen, dass die Rogue-O-Matic hieß das Programm, es nicht schlägt. Also es gab auch einen kleinen sportlichen Ehrgeiz. Also nicht, dass ich das selber erlebt hätte, aber das ist eine Anekdote zu lieben. Fand ich auch. Fand ich auch spannend.
Ja, das ist immer das Schöne, dass UNIX und dieses ganze Terminal-Prinzip einem gerade so eine Automatisierung generell immer sehr einfach gemacht hat. War ja auch lange Zeit eigentlich so, sagen wir mal, die primäre Suchwirkung von UNIX-Systemen, dass man eben über Skripte da sehr schnell Automatisierung herbeiführen kann. Und kein Wunder, dass sich das so für Server heutzutage so durchgesetzt hat.
Ich fand auch interessant, dass diese Idee des Spielens, dass da sozusagen, also dass das auch so eine große kreative Kraft entfaltet, dass dann eben dann auch auf einmal dann Dinge rauskommen, die dann auch sehr anspruchsvoll und sehr ernsthaft sind. Also das finde ich auch einen interessanten Aspekt an Computerspielen generell. Also das ist irgendwie auch eine treibende Kraft sein kann. Also es ist nicht nur verballert, wobei ich auch den, wie hieß der Mensch, Richie oder der Herr von Dennis Richie zitiert wird, dass wohl mit keinem Programm mehr CPU-Zeit verschwendet wurde als aus mit Rogue. Also es wurde wahrscheinlich sehr viel gespielt damals in den Universitäten.
Also das Spiel lief ja auf UNIX.
Genau, das lief damals tatsächlich, genau, die hatten ja bei Berkeley glaube ich auch den Luxus da ihr eigenes Derivat zu haben und zu entwickeln und da wurde das meines Wissens auch drauf betrieben. Und dass das portiert wurde, kam glaube ich erst bei Rogue glaube ich, weiß ich auch nicht genau, erst sehr viel später, also dass es da PC-Versionen oder sowas gab. Anders als, weiß ich nicht genau, war ich schon, soll ich einfach mal...
Mich wäre ja noch mal interessieren, so Rogue, also wie muss man sich denn das jetzt so vorstellen? Also du hast ja gesagt, das User-Interface wurde gemalt, aber was war denn jetzt sozusagen das User-Interface?
Die Idee ist eigentlich die von der Darstellung her, dass man halt eine Aufsicht hat auf das Spiel. Also das ist diese...
Wie so eine Landkarte.
Genau, wie eine Landkarte oder das heißt, es kommt ja auch dieses, das Rollenspielsystem, was dem zugrunde liegt, ist D&D heißt es, Dungeons & Dragons, was glaube ich Ende der 70er Jahre, Mitte, Ende der 70er Jahre entwickelt wurde. Also wenn man das Pen- und Paper-Rollenspiel kennt, dann fällt einem das auch unmittelbar auf, weil die Monster gleich heißen und auch diese Attribute, die der Spieler hat und so, das ist alles eins zu eins. Ich glaube, die mussten dann später auch Sachen rausnehmen, um keinen Ärger zu kriegen mit den D&D-Leuten oder umbenennen. Also auf jeden Fall ist es ein Dungeon, den man da sieht. Also das ist sowas wie ein Höhensystem oder ein Verlies, kann man sagen. Und was man bekommt, ist eine Aufsicht. Man startet in einem Raum. Das muss man sich eben so vorstellen, dass man eben mit einfachen ASCII-Charaktern, die sich eigenen, also solche Sachen wie Pipesymbole, Sankt-Unterstrich, genau eben die Umrandung von diesem Raum macht. Und dann sind Räume verbunden durch Korridorteile, das sind dann zum Beispiel Hashmarks. Und eben ein Algorithmus, der nach zufälligen, aber eben doch in gewissen Rahmen-definierten Regeln diesen Dungeon macht. Also, man fängt dort an in einem Raum, dann hat man dort einen Durchgang, ein Korridor, geht da rein, dann kann der sich verzweigen in einen anderen Raum, der kann eine beliebige Größe haben. In den Räumen werden dann Gegenstände und Monster dargestellt, das sind dann...
Aber man sieht ja erstmal nichts, ne?
Man sieht erstmal, doch, man sieht, wenn der Raum nicht dunkel ist, was es auch gibt, aber ich glaube, die Startlevel hat man das noch nicht, sieht man den... Gut, ich will jetzt nicht, dass ich selber Rogue gespielt habe, das will ich jetzt nicht so weit auseinander aus dem Fenster lehnen, aber ich sage mal, man sieht den ersten Raum, sieht man komplett. Es gibt noch keine Türen, man sieht dann den Korridor. Und dann sieht man halt immer, man sieht halt immer acht, die acht Felder um sich herum und dann nochmal... Gut, okay, jetzt weiß ich nicht genau, wie das bei Rogue ist, aber auf jeden Fall, man kann ein paar Felder weit gucken.
Okay, aber das Prinzip ist erstmal, man hat quasi so ein landkartenartige Verlies-Idee, ja, Räume, die irgendwie mit Tunneln miteinander verbunden sind und da kann man umher marschieren.
Genau, richtig. Die sind dann gefüllt mit... Das ist ja ein Abendrücker, die sind dann gefüllt mit Dingen, mit Monstern natürlich. Also es ist natürlich eine große Freude gewesen, einfach nur diese Monster zu slaschen, ja, und dafür braucht man natürlich Waffen, dann gibt es Waffen, dafür braucht man sowas wie Magie, dann gibt es irgendwie Zauber-Sprüche, die man da in Form von Schriftrollen aufnehmen kann, die man dann lesen kann und die dann einen Effekt haben, wobei man, wie gesagt, oftmals bei der ersten Anwendung nicht sicher sein kann, was es wirklich ist, weil die Dinge oft mit Synonymen belegt sind, ebenso um diese Zufälligkeit da reinzubringen. Also es ist immer auch eine Art von Erforschung des Environments, das ist immer mit ihm begriffen. Ja, ich weiß gar nicht genau, das ist so das klassische Spielprinzip und das baut sich dann halt in Ebenen auf. Also man hat dann halt ein Dungeon-Level und dann gibt es halt immer einen Durchgang nach unten oder nach oben, wie nach dem, also und kann dann halt in den nächsten Level hinabsteigen, um dort irgendwie ein ähnliches Vergnügen wieder zu durchleben, solange bis man im untersten Dungeon angekommen ist. Ziel des Spiels ist es und also war es bei Rogue auch, den Wizard of Yendor zu erlegen und ihm seines magischen Amuletts zu berauben.
Das Amulett von Yendor.
Genau, von Yendor. Und was ich auch Yendor... Oh Gott, lass mich jetzt nichts Falsches sagen.
Worauf jetzt jetzt hinaus auf den Namen?
Genau, das ist doch umgedreht für... Rotney, genau. Und es war der Name des Spielers bei Rogue. Ich weiß, wenn man angefangen hat, man konnte sich den Spielernamen nicht aussuchen, sondern man war immer Rotney. Und das ist sozusagen ein kleiner Witz.
Man war immer Rotney.
So habe ich das zumindest gelesen. Ich kann mich daran auch nicht mehr genau erinnern.
So wie man an anderen Orten vielleicht Bernd heißt.
Ja, genau, richtig.
Wir sagen jetzt aber nicht wo.
Genau. Auf jeden Fall erfreute sich dieses Spiel großer Beliebtheit.
Im UNIX-Lager.
Im UNIX-Lager, genau. In den Universitäten.
Das waren jetzt noch keine Massen.
Das waren aber doch sehr viele Leute, die das wohl gespielt haben müssen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz gab es Leute, die dachten, das könnte man anders und besser machen. Da geht noch was. Und das ist eben auch die Geburtschunde von diesem Rogue-like-Genre, wo dann einfach Leute sich hingesetzt haben und diese Code-Bases genommen haben und das erweitert haben.
Also es kam sozusagen auch im Source?
Ja, es kam auch im Source. Es muss auch im Source gekommen sein, auf jeden Fall. Denn ich weiß, das Hack ist wirklich so eine direkte Abkömmling davon.
Das heißt, es gab Rogue?
Genau, dann gab es Leute, die sich hingesetzt haben und Rogue verändert haben. Und daraus entstand, ich glaube, 1984, Ende 84, der erste Release oder Anfang 85 von einem Spiel namens Hack. Bei dem initialen Posting, das wurde damals alles, es gab ja noch kein World Wide Web, das wurde ja glaube ich erst Anfang der 90er, da gab es den ersten Web-Server. Sondern es gab halt andere Protokolle, mit denen Informationen im Internet ausgetauscht wurden, andere Dienste. Und für diese Art von Kommunikation, die sich hier im NetHack- und Hack- und Rogue-Umfeld sehr beliebt war, waren die Newsnet-Newsgroups, wo es extra Newsgroups gab, in denen sowohl der Source Code als auch die Binary oder eben auch Informationen über die Spiele, Spielverläufe, wo sich die Leute darüber ausgetauscht haben, was man machen kann, wie Strategien sind zu überleben und Ideen gesammelt haben. Und das lief alles viel im Newsnet ab. Und da wurde auch die erste Version von Hack gepostet in 17 Posts, soweit ich das recherchiert habe. In einer, ich glaube sogar noch in einer Rogue-Newsgroup, wo sich dann ziemlich schnell wegen dem vielen Andrang und der Fülle der Interessenten eine Hack, Alt-Games-Hack, glaube ich, gegründet hat, wo dann sich das weiter abgespielt hat.
Das muss man ja nochmal sagen, war ja damals sozusagen das, was, sagen wir mal, dem heutigen Web als Tummelplatz noch am nächsten kam, auch wenn es überhaupt nicht im Ansatz auch nur so eine Struktur hatte, sondern es war ja mehr so ein weltweites Forum mit so einer hierarchischen Bretterstruktur. Übrigens, also von Rogue gab es keinen Source Code, deswegen wurde Hack sozusagen komplett neu gemacht. Also es war sozusagen nur die Inspiration, aber der Source Code kam wohl irgendwie nicht raus. Das heißt, und dann war Hack quasi so der Hack halt, um das irgendwie, weil ich meine, sonst hättest du wahrscheinlich auch als Rogue weitergelebt, nehme ich mal an.
Ja, ich finde das gut, okay, ja gut. Ich finde das erstaunlich, aber gut, ja.
Ja, das war halt auch irgendwie Open Source, was heute so allgemeingültig zu sein scheint, ja, war damals nicht der Standard, so, sondern Software war halt, wurde halt von Entwicklern gemacht und dann hat man irgendwie eben das Bannerie gespielt und dieser Wunsch, gerade bei dieser Vielzahl von existierenden UNIX-Plattformen, die ja dann eben alle irgendwie ein bisschen anders waren, dasselbe auch zu haben, hat dann dazu geführt, zwangsläufig, dass eben, dass der einzige viable Weg war, Software überhaupt universell einsetzen zu können, weil im Source Code auszuliefern. Und da entstanden ja dann auch diese ganzen Bildsysteme, diese ganzen absurden Skripte, die irgendwie erstmal durch das Betriebssystem durchforsteten und schauten, wo bin ich denn hier eigentlich, was ist es denn, was ist es denn nicht? Wie könnte ich jetzt diese Software übersetzen?
Ja, beziehungsweise, ich glaube, diese Autokonfigurationsgeschichten kamen noch später, glaube ich. Also wenn man sich das Makefile von NetHack anguckt, da ist durchforsteter System noch nicht sehr viel automatisch, welche Bibliotheken schon da sind, sondern da muss man sehr viel Handarbeit leisten.
Genau, das waren dann sozusagen die Konsequenzen daraus, genau.
Sehr viel Handarbeit, Leistung zu machen. Ja, okay, dann haben wir das geklärt. Dann haben die Jungs also das tatsächlich damals zum ersten Mal mit Hack dann im Source-Code veröffentlicht, was ja auch dazu führte, dass das auf einer sehr breiten Plattform lief, und dass viele Leute das portiert haben.
Mhm, genau.
Was auch zum Beispiel dazu führte, dass ich irgendwann mal dieses wunderbaren Spiels haphaf wurde, weil nämlich auch jemand sich netterweise hingesetzt hat und es für den Atari ST portiert hat, den ich zu dieser Zeit zu Hause hatte, mit Ende der 80er, und so dann auch in die Genuss kam, dieses Spiel zu spielen. Ich weiß noch, ein Freund meines Vaters, das muss wirklich ein Nord gewesen sein, der hat uns diese Diskette in die Hand gedrückt, da standen diese vier Buchstaben drauf, Hack, und dazu gab es einen Pfeiler, so einen Ordner, mit etwa anderthalb Zentimeter ausgedrucktem Papier. Das war dann die Anleitung des Spiels plus irgendwie ausgedruckte Newsgroups, wo halt so das Spiel erklärt wurde und welche Tipps dafür waren. Und ich war erstmal irritiert, muss ich sagen, ich habe leidenschaftlich gern gespielt, aber es war irgendwie doch eine ziemliche Hürde, erstmal dachte ich, so viel zu lesen, denn es ist tatsächlich so, man muss halt relativ viele Kommandos erstmal lernen. Fast jedes Zeichen auf der Tastatur macht irgendwas Bestimmtes. Und ich habe es auch erstmal glaube ich wieder zur Seite gelegt. Erst als ich dann in diesem Ordner gefunden habe, so tabellarische Anordnung von irgendwie Waffen- und Monstersystemen, die mich irgendwie sehr an meine Rollenspielerfahrung erinnert haben und auch in einem Detailgrad da drin waren, wo ich dachte, oh, das ist ja der Wahnsinn, wurde mir so, dämmerte mir, worum es da eigentlich geht. Nämlich so darum, diese klassischen Pen- und Paper-Rollenspiele wirklich halt in einem Computerspiel, auch in ihrer Komplexität, die sie da hatten, versuchen einzubauen und mir die Möglichkeit zu geben, eben diese tollen, spaßigen Erfahrungen, die ich da mit meinen Freunden, mit den Pen- und Paper-Rollenspielen zu habe, in einer gewissen Art und Weise halt auch, wenn ich gerade Lust hatte, am Computer zu haben und zu spielen. Also das war wirklich ein Aha-Moment, das sind natürlich Sachen, die Leute, die aus dem Sourcecode extrahiert haben, wo dann sehr detailliert drin stand, auch in so Rollenspieler-Terminologie, also was ich zum Beispiel, die Waffe XY macht, 3d4 plus 2 Punkte Schaden oder das Monster kann gegessen werden oder nicht gegessen werden oder kann lesen, kann nicht lesen. Und ich meine, das waren nicht ein oder zwei Monster, das waren halt Hunderte. Also das waren Hunderte von Waffen. Also man hatte wirklich, oder nicht Hunderte von Waffen, aber Dutzende zumindest. Also man hatte schon, als man da diese ausgedruckten News-Postings gelesen hat, den Eindruck, das ist wirklich relativ komplex. Und das hat mich dann auch motiviert, mich da hinzusetzen und diese Lernkurve, die man da auf jeden Fall durchlaufen muss, auf mich zu nehmen. Und als ich da erstmal dabei war, hörte das auch nicht mehr auf. Also es war dann wirklich, wenn man erstmal, und es war auch nicht so schlimm, wie ich es mir vorgestellt habe, man kann ziemlich schnell, wenn man sich hier rumbewegen kann, das geht dann alles, gibt es halt, geht dann alles relativ schnell, dass man das halbwegs spielen kann. Und ich hatte auch, glaube ich, das Glück, dass einer meiner Brüder auch Feuer gefangen hat, und man sich dann immer austauschen konnte und eben gemeinsame Erfahrungen austauschen konnte. Und das war auf jeden Fall so für mich dann der Anfang. Also das war natürlich auch dieser Portierung, weil es gab natürlich diese UNIX-Systeme natürlich in erster Linie im Universitären und im Forschungsbereich, aber zu Hause hatte natürlich niemand so ein Ding da mal zu stehen.
Also es gab Rogue, Rogue hat die Idee geboren, ein Rollenspiel mal als Computergame zu machen und dabei auch noch dieses ganze, eigentlich das, was im normalen Rollenspiel so der Master übernimmt, so der Spielleiter, dass der eben auch, sagen wir mal, die Unwägbarkeiten mit reinbringt, dass Dinge mal anders sind und dass man in gewisser Hinsicht auch auf das, was sich die Spieler alles einfallen lassen, dann auch kreativ reagiert, was ja unter anderem einen den Reiz ausmacht.
So ist es.
Und dann wollten die aber den Sourcecode nicht rausgeben, und die Leute waren aber jetzt angefixt und wollten irgendwie auch mal, und dann haben sie es einfach davon inspiriert, quasi neu geschrieben, das, was sie daran mochten, mehr oder weniger beibehalten, also die Art und Weise, wie das User-Interface sich präsentierte, und dann hackgeschrieben, gepostet, und dann war es irgendwie im Netz. Und wie verhält sich jetzt NetHack zu Hack?
Ich würde sagen, NetHack verhält sich zu Hack genauso ähnlich, wie sich vielleicht Hack zu Rogue verhält. Es ist halt nochmal eine erhebliche Stufe mehr Komplexität dazu gekommen, im Sinne von, ich würde keine Ahnung, wie man es beziffern kann, verzehnfacht vielleicht über die Zeit. Das ist natürlich auch eine Entwicklung. Ich meine, die NetHack-Entwicklung setzt ja dann mehr oder weniger relativ kurz danach. Also ich glaube, 1985 ist das Hack gepostet worden. Dann 1987 ging das mit der NetHack-Entwicklung los. Ich glaube, derang großer, was auch eine spezielle Sache, was auch den Namen ausmacht, so zumindest geht die Legende, dass das NetHack heißt, dass es halt auch von einer breiteren Entwicklerschaft entwickelt wurde, dadurch dass es eben übers Newsnet, also übers Internet damals möglich wurde, halt gemeinsam Software zu entwickeln. Also es ist sozusagen so was wie heute's Sourceforge oder so, die Möglichkeit den Leuten, also wenn man sich das anguckt, dass bei den Spielen davor gab es halt immer zwei oder drei Leute, bei Hack dann vielleicht noch ein paar Leute, die die Ports dafür geschrieben haben, aber das Entwicklerteam bei NetHack wuchs halt stetig. Und das wurde natürlich dann auch über die lange Zeit, die die daran entwickelt haben, ich glaube der letzte Release ist 2003 gewesen, also 14 Jahre, 13 Jahre, natürlich kontinuierlich verbessert, komplizierter, verrückter, trickier, unschaffbarer vielleicht. Also das...
Das heißt NetHack ist quasi dann die Weiterentwicklung von Hack gewesen, also man hat das sozusagen genommen und irgendwie da jeder was zu sagen hatte und jeder was zu kontributieren hatte und jeder irgendeine Finesse ausbauen wollte, war es so quasi unumstößlich, dass man das zu so einem Community-Projekt werden lässt und dann hat man den Namen einfach entsprechend angepasst.
Genau, wobei diese Community, glaube ich, dieses Developer-Team dann doch eine relativ... Also es waren zwar, sagen wir mal, ich würde mal sagen, wenn man in die License guckt, vielleicht 30 Leute oder sowas, aber eben nicht so wie man das alle Leute Ideen posten konnten oder Code posten konnten, sondern es wurde denen auch, glaube ich, oft ein bisschen angekreidet, eher dann schon eher eine eingeschworene Gemeinde, die schon viele Leute aber eben dann doch sehr ihre Ideen dort verfolgt haben. Und das führte auch zu anderen Roguelike-Spinoffs wie Slash zum Beispiel, die sie, glaube ich, NetHack genommen haben und gesagt haben, die sind uns zu konservativ, wir bauen das jetzt. Ist auch ein Akronym, glaube ich. Ich weiß das jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber...
Slash'em.
Superlotzer-added-stuff-hack-extended-magic.
Also dort haben sich dann wieder Leute gefunden, die dann eben noch verrückter Sachen oder diese relativ konservative, in Anführungszeichen, Entwicklungsstrategie von den NetHack-Developer-Team zu langweilig fanden.
Extra-Features, Monsters und Items.
Genau. Zum Teil sind dann aber auch Sachen wieder zurückgeflossen in NetHack. Also ich glaube zum Beispiel, im Magiesystem sind dann Sachen auch tatsächlich später dann noch eingeflossen. Zum Glück. Die sind wirklich schön. Also das ist sozusagen so ein bisschen, sage ich, der historische Ablauf. Und auch die Anzahl der supporteden Plattformen ist auf jeden Fall, auch natürlich über die Zeit, weil natürlich auch mehr Systeme auf den Markt kamen, denke ich mal. Aber es gibt glaube ich kaum ein Programm, was auf einer Code-Base so viele unterschiedliche Hardware-Plattformen unterstützt wie NetHack. Also ich kann mich erinnern, als ich in die Uni kam, gab es kein NetHack. Und das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ich habe versucht NetHack zu bauen. Und dann, wenn man durch dieses Mac-File geht und sieht, was da alles damals drin war, da irgendwie OS2, irgendwie VMS, MS-DOS, Microsoft, Windows, es gab unterschiedliche UNIX-Dirivate. Aber vor allem auch alle erdenklichen UNIX-Dirivate.
Genau, alle erdenklichen UNIX-Dirivate.
Mit allen erdenklichen, genau, und eh nach dem, mit was für Features die kamen, mit was für Parsern, Bison, Flex, was es da nicht alles gab. Also man musste sein System schon ziemlich gut auch kennen, um da diesen Make-Prozess entsprechend zu konfigurieren. Aber, also es ging, wenn man sich etwas Liebe da reingesteckt hat. Oder je nachdem, wie versiert man halt war. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich damals in dem UNI im Rechenzentrum den Operator, der habe ich um Hilfe gebeten und der war natürlich kein Problem. Und der hat dann aber ziemlich schnell die Lust verloren, weil das nämlich doch ganz schön kompliziert war.
Das heißt, man kann auch sagen, dass NetHack im Prinzip vielleicht nicht das erste, aber doch zumindest eine der ersten nennenswerten Open-Source-Developments war, wo da jetzt vielleicht auch nicht jeder mit programmieren konnte, aber wo zumindest eine extrem große und ich vermute mal auch global recht verteilte Entwicklerschaft dran gearbeitet hat und auch das Feedback des ganzen Netzes kontinuierlich aufgenommen hat und integriert hat.
Also das denke ich auf jeden Fall, das mit dem Feedback ist sicher richtig. Und inwieweit zu der Zeit andere Software-Projekte Ähnliches gemacht haben, weiß ich natürlich nicht genau, aber ich denke schon, dass das nicht sehr verbreitet war. Das war halt wahrscheinlich wirklich ein Novum, eine Neuigkeit.
Also vor allem als Spiel, also vor allem als richtige, klar es gab ja auch E-Mail-Clients und halt diese ganze Infrastruktur, die eben in der Zeit dann auf UNIX gewachsen ist, aber es ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt besonders viele Spiele gab, wenn man so ein UNIX installiert hat.
Nein.
Und von daher war NetHack, das war immer so ein bisschen meine Wahrnehmung, also ich habe das ein wenig gespielt. Ich bin nicht so ein Spieler-Hardcore-Typ, weil ich immer so früh offen bin, immer so früh beleidigt, wenn ich verliere. Ich gebe das zu, ja. Hatte aber trotzdem irgendwie einen riesen Spaß an diesem NetHack, was auf meinem Rechner natürlich lief, was in dem Fall, glaube ich, ein Xenix-System war. Vor allem, weil, da kannst du vielleicht nochmal was dazu sagen, weil man ja während dieses Spiel spielte, einem das Betriebssystem nicht so fern blieb.
Ja, also ich weiß, worauf du anspielst, glaube ich. Du spielst auf diese Geschichte mit dem Mailer-Demon an. Also es ist auch immer noch so, wenn man auf einem System spielt, wo man sein eigenes Mailfach hat, was auf UNIX-Systemen üblich war. So musste man auf jeden Fall seiner E-Mail nicht entgehen, während man stundenlang spielte, sondern das Programm hat gemerkt, wenn eine E-Mail im Postfach ankam, und dann gab es einen Monster, den sogenannten Mailer-Demon, der dann als kaufmännisches Und, als Ambassadent, einem entgegengerannt kam und sagte, You got mail, I'm a scroll of mail, in die Hand gab. Und dann konnte man, wenn man sagte, R für Read, und dann den entsprechenden Scroll aus seinem Inventory ausgesucht hatte, in-game sozusagen dieser Post lesen.
Das ist wirklich so großartig. Ich weiß auch nicht, als ich das das erste Mal hatte, hat mich so weggelegen.
Es hat halt auch diesen Charme mit dem Witz, dass man auch diese Programme, die ja die Mail verwalten, sind ja die Demons in, also das ist der Mail-Demon. Und das hat natürlich total gepasst auch in diesen Fantasy-Kontext, dass dann auch der Dämon tatsächlich persönlich vorbeikam und you got mail und dann hat er dann auch immer was gesagt. Und dann hat er glaube ich immer noch gesagt, er muss schnell wieder weg, er hat keine Zeit und dann weg war. Und dann konnte man den irgendwie lesen. Man konnte sonst nicht so viel damit machen. Das hätte wahrscheinlich auch die Game-Balance zerstört. Und vielleicht auch die eigene Post, meine mit anderen Scrolls, die kann man ja dann in Wasser tunken und dann werden sie gelöscht. Und dann kann man sie neu beschreiben, das ging mit den Mail-Scrolls zum Beispiel nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ob die verbrannt sind, wenn man ans Feuer kam, aber ich nehme an, nicht.
Mir fällt auch noch eine zweite Integration ein.
Aha, da bin ich ja, ja bitte.
Und zwar, korrigiere mich, wenn das nicht stimmt, aber soweit ich mich erinnere, war es so, dass wenn man das Spiel startete und es war Vollmond, dann startete es, glaube ich, gleich hoch mit You're Lucky, Full Moon Tonight.
Oder You're Lucky, ja, genau.
Und hatte man da nicht mehr Glück?
Genau, und New Moon gibt es auch, You're Lucky, warte mal, lass mich mal kurz überlegen. Genau, und bei Neumond hatte man mehr Wehrkreaturen und tatsächlich die ominöse Glücksvariable, die es in diesem Spiel gibt, Quell vieler Spekulation, ist davon beeinflusst auf jeden Fall, wie die Mondphase ist. Das hat natürlich nicht direkt mit dem Betriebssystem zu tun, weil man braucht ein System mit einem Kalender und dann ist da eine Mondphasenberechnung mit dem Spiel drin. Das ging auf andere Systeme auch.
Das waren einfach Konzepte, die waren zu dem Zeitpunkt einfach komplett neu. Also, dass ein Spiel in irgendeiner Form auf diese Art und Weise auf das System zurückgreift und das dann einfach spielerisch mit einbaut. Ich glaube, das hat auch echt viel von diesem Appeal ausgemacht. Warum dieses Spiel so eine unglaubliche Begeisterung hatte. Ich habe jetzt gerade im Vorfeld noch mal gehört, hier so Unis generell. Also konkret weiß ich jetzt hier von der Uni in Ulm. Die hatten also extra einen ihrer Server, ausschließlich dafür abgestellt, NetHack-Server zu sein. Also so Anfang der 90er Jahre. Das muss man jetzt mal unter diesem Kontext sehen, dass einen Server überhaupt erst mal zu haben damals schon eine Errungenschaft war. So einen ganzen Computer sozusagen alleine. Dass man da überhaupt erst mal ein Spiel drauf haben konnte, aber dass der dann mehr oder weniger auch für nichts anderes zutünnig war. Das war schon echt ein Luxus und sagt auch einiges darüber aus, wie groß die Begeisterung damals dafür war.
Ja, wollte ich auch denken. Also das war sicherlich ein sehr beliebtes Spiel. Also diese News-Postings, die es da gab, also es wurde wirklich und wird glaube ich auch immer noch weltweit von vielen Leuten gemocht und auch gespielt. Also es ist ja auch ein tolles Spiel.
Genau, kommen wir noch mal so ein bisschen zu dem Spiel.
Eine Sache fällt mir noch ein, auch zur Integration, was ich gerade drüber nachgedacht habe. Zum Beispiel, dass, also nicht sehr viele, aber es gibt viele Sachen, die zum Beispiel so aus diesem UNIX-Texteditor-Feld kommen. Also zum Beispiel, wie man das Monster bewegt, also sich selbst bewegt. Das ist ja auch kein Monster, sondern ein Mensch. Es sind diese VI-Keybindings, also wo man halt... Genau, wo ich am Anfang ja verzweifelt bin. Man kann dann auch auf... Daran erkennt man......Numberpad umschalten, dann kann man mit den Cursor-Tasten, aber...
Aber daran erkennt man wirklich einen Oldschooler.
Ja, ich möchte das ja nicht mehr missen.
Wenn du ein VI startest, womit steuerst du deinen Cursor?
Natürlich mit... Ja, ich auch. Und ich bin auch früher bei jedem anderen Programm, das mir die Möglichkeit gibt, das zu tun. Mir gibt es zum Glück viele, die das immer noch unterstützen.
Ich habe schon Twitter-Kleins kennengelernt auf dem Mac, die das machen.
Das geht nicht weg. Und auch...
Es gab ja auch häufig einfach gar keine Cursor-Tasten.
Genau.
Also das war einfach nicht auf den Tastaturen, gab es einfach keine Cursor-Tasten. Da war man schon ganz froh, wenn man so steuern konnte.
Genau. Und man brauchte auch die diagonalen Tasten noch irgendwie für schräg nach oben, schräg nach unten, links und rechts. Bei NetHack ist es total sinnvoll, weil man dann...
Was war denn das? War das dann U, I, O, N, M oder was?
Das ist dann... Genau. Muss ich mal raufgucken. Genau, aber so ist es. Also du gehst dann mit U nach oben rechts, mit B nach unten links, mit Z nach oben links.
Nach Z, U und B und N?
Genau.
Echt? Warum denn nicht U, I, N, M?
Z, N, B, U sind die für links, rechts und unten Ecken. Oder auch so Sachen wie I, dass man halt, wenn man Dinge mehrmals tun möchte, dass man da die Nummer davor schreibt. Geht bei NetHack auch. Also wenn du jetzt 10 Felder nach links gehen willst, dann kannst du sagen 10 J. 10 J, 10 H, Entschuldige. Ja genau.
10 H nach links.
Genau. Also diese Sachen haben sie auch da adaptiert. Also da gibt es auch noch ein paar andere Sachen, die sich so wahrscheinlich aus Gewohnheit da einfach eingeschlichen haben.
Warum sollte man sich in einem Dungeon anders bewegen als in einem Texteditor?
Genau, das fehlt mir gerade auch noch ein. Das ist auch noch eine Analogie vielleicht zu dem UNIX-Welt.
Ja, bei uns fallen sicherlich noch ein paar Sachen ein. Wie geht es jetzt los? Also ich starte das Spiel und im Wesentlichen sehe ich einen Raum oder so.
Genau, so ist das, genau.
Und ich bin ein Ad.
Und du bist ein Ad, genau. Das Ad ist das Zeichen für das Monster vom Typ Mensch sozusagen.
Also es gibt auch noch andere Ads.
Ja, es gibt auch noch andere Ads, genau. Also zum Beispiel ganz klassisch, seit es Hack gibt, gibt es Shops und Shopkeeper. Also man kann sozusagen einkaufen gehen im Dungeon und die Shopkeeper sind erstmal Menschen. Es gibt auch noch jede Menge andere Menschen wie Priester oder Krankenschwestern, fallen mir ein. Also es gibt etliche, wieder auch als Außereiben. Man ist nicht ganz allein als Mensch. Wobei die Masse der Kreaturen doch eher nicht so menschlich ist.
Und wenn du jetzt NetHack startest, wüsstest du immer sofort bei jedem Zeichen, was das für ein Monster ist?
Also ich wüsste es, es ist so, dass es so viele Monster gibt, dass nicht alle Zeichen und Farben ausreichen, um sie alle eindeutig zu identifizieren. Also es ist dann so, spontan fällt mir ein, das kleine weiße D, was man zum Beispiel als Hund hat, als Hund, es könnte ein kleiner oder ein großer Hund sein, es könnte aber glaube ich auch, ich bin nicht ganz sicher, kann das auch ein Eiswolf sein? Also es gibt auf jeden Fall da, es gibt Dinge, die nicht ganz eindeutig sind, aber in der Regel kriegt man das raus und es gibt auch immer die Möglichkeit, mit der Slash-Taste ein Objekt zu identifizieren. Entweder man kann mit dem Cursor direkt draufgehen und sagen, sag mir mal, was das ist, oder man kann den Namen eingeben und dann gibt es eine längliche Beschreibung, wenn man will.
Also so Slash-D-Return, dann kriege ich irgendwie einen Hund.
Genau, dann kriegst du eine Beschreibung, was auch sehr schön ist zum Teil. Also es gibt wirklich für jedes Monster, was da drin ist, noch mal eine längere oder kürzere Textbeschreibung. Oft sind die sehr malerisch oder sind halt irgendwie Zitate aus irgendwelchen Büchern oder Enzyklopedien an. Also es ist jetzt auch so, dass man, wo man ja diese sehr rudimentäre Grafik hat, die doch in zumindest seiner Vorstellung dann anreichern kann mit Bildern, wenn man entsprechend sich diese Textfalls durchliest. Also wenn du sagst slash und dann dog und dann gibt es eine genaue Beschreibung, was das halt ist. Ein Hund. Und das geht halt für alle Monster und es gibt wirklich viele. Also da hat man sich, also da sieht man auch ein bisschen wie viel Liebe und Mühe da in diesem ganzen Ding drin steht. Das ist auch ein Steck, der auch an solchen Stellen. Genau. Ja, hast du dich randomisieren lassen? Okay, also es gibt dir wohl die Möglichkeit, einen Charakter auszusuchen oder sich einen quasi geben zu lassen. Genau. Und was siehst du, Tim? Du siehst einen Raum nehme ich an mit einer Tür, mit einer Treppe nach oben. Das ist das Kleine Zeichen. Genau. Also du bist jetzt im Dungeon Level 1 sozusagen auf der ersten Ebene. Wenn du dort jetzt die Treppe raufgehen würdest, würdest du das Spiel wieder verlassen. Es sei denn, du bist im Besitz des Amulets auf Yendor. Dann könntest du von dort in die Astralebene aufsteigen. Aber das kommt erst ganz zum Schluss. Und ehrlich gesagt, mir ist es noch nicht. Gelungen. Und was man noch sieht, ist ein D oder ein F. Es ist entweder ein Hund oder eine Katze.
Ich habe ja ein F.
Genau, das ist sozusagen dein Haustier. Dein Pet, das ist ein zahmes Tier, was dich bei deiner Reise durch den Dungeon unterstützt.
Generell?
Generell, genau. Also der kämpft für dich, der hilft dir.
Also F ist dann die Katze.
F ist die Katze, genau.
Sofieline.
Genau.
Rex heißt das Tier.
Genau, du kannst dem aber auch einen Namen geben. Beliebig, dem allen Objekten und auch allen Monstern und allen kannst du auch Namen geben, mit denen sie dann auch dann erscheinen in dem Spiel.
Tim, sie ist Evoker, heiß ich.
Ja, genau. Evoker ist praktisch der unterste Level deiner Klasse als Wizard. Also als Evoker. Verstehe. Du kannst dann später alles Mögliche, Sorcerer und so weiter.
Kann ich auch Enchanter werden?
Ja, du kannst auch Enchanter werden.
Echt? Ich kann Tim the Enchanter sein?
Du wirst Tim the Enchanter.
Wie lange muss ich da spielen, bis ich Tim the Enchanter bin?
Ich weiß nicht genau, welchem numerischem Level der Enchanter entspricht, aber vielleicht gar nicht so lange. Genau, das kann man ja kurz erklären. Das ist wie in einem klassischen Rollenspiel für die Leute, die das vielleicht nicht so kennen. Es gibt halt irgendwie Attribute, über die der Charakter definiert ist. Also was wie Stärke, Geschicklichkeit, Konstitution, Intelligenz, Weisheit, Charisma. Und es gibt natürlich auch sowas wie Leveling. Also man kann sozusagen, fängt mit Null Experience sozusagen Level 1 an und dann Experience Level 1 und wird dann entsprechend hochgelevelt. Und wenn man hochlevelt, erinnern sich dann auch entsprechend die Attribute werden dann also erhöht. Und man hat mehr Hitpoints. Hitpoints hat man natürlich auch, weil es gibt natürlich auch darum, eventuell dem Risiko ausgesetzt zu sein zu sterben. Das passiert unter anderem, wenn die Hitpoints auf Null gesunken sind. Man kann auch sterben, indem man verhungert. Oder was geht noch? Lass mal überlegen.
Also Charisma, Intelligenz, was sagt das so noch?
Konstitution.
Das ist eine Eigenschaft oder ein Zustand?
Das ist sozusagen, wie das bei Die und Die ist, ist das ein Wert zwischen, ich denke wahrscheinlich 3 und 18 oder so was? Oder 3 und, ja ich glaube 6, 18, genau, wahrscheinlich 3D6 nehme ich an. Zwischen 3 und 18. Und 18 ist das Maximum.
Also 3D6 heißt?
Drei sechseitige Würfelwürfel, wenn man den Charakter einer Weise erschafft. Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, wie das bei Die und Die ist, weil das auch schon ein bisschen her ist, als ich das gespielt habe, aber ich sage mal. Und umso höher dieser Wert, umso stärker ist diese Eigenschaft. Das heißt, bei Stärke geht es zum Beispiel, wenn du auf einen Monster einschlägst, deinen Stärke-Bonus mit ein. Das heißt, dann gibt es halt irgendwie einen stärkeren Schaden, wenn du stärker bist oder wenn du eine Tür auftreten willst. Oder eben alle Dinge, wovon jemand meint. Oder ganz klassisch, wie viele Gegenstände du mit dir herumtragen kannst, bevor deine Bewegung eingeschränkt wird. Das sind zum Beispiel so klassische Geschichten, wo die Stärke eine Rolle spielt. Dexterity spielt auf jeden Fall eine Rolle, wenn man z.B. Fernwaffen benutzt, also sowas wie Bogenschießen oder...
Wie kann ich denn ein Read-Raw machen?
Ctrl-Shift-A. Ctrl-R-A, ja. Also, das ist einerseits Widerstandskraft, andererseits auch, umso höher deine Konstitution ist. Condi... Condition? Konstitution? Condition. Okay, also umso höher dieser Wert, umso stärker steigen deine Hitpoints an. Deine maximalen Hitpoints, wenn du levels. Also wenn du sehr robust bist, dann nehmen die halt auch stärker zu. Intelligenz, wichtig für alles, was mit Magie und Zaubern zu tun hat. Sag ich mal. I don't know. Ehrlich gesagt.
Die Weisheit.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht genau, was das wirklich…
Weiß ich nicht. Normalerweise ist das doch dann immer so die Fähigkeit soziale Konflikte…
Ja, das ist aber, glaube ich, eher Charisma, also das Charisma, also sozusagen wie Monster auf dich reagieren, ob die grundsätzlich… Monster, wo das nicht ganz klar ist, ob die dich angreifen oder nicht. Wenn du charismatischer bist, hast du da bessere Chancen oder wenn du zum Beispiel einen Shopkeeper gegen dich aufgebracht hast, wenn du versucht hast, ihn zu bestehen, mit Absicht oder unabsichtlich, wie der auf dich reagiert und solche Sachen werden darüber abgehandelt. Gibt es sowas? Ja, genau. Hitpoints hatten wir schon. Da gibt es Powerpoints natürlich, das ist das Äquivalent zu Hitpoints für die Magie. Wenn man gerne zaubern möchte, gibt es auch Charaktere, die dafür mehr oder weniger begabt sind. Also Charakterklassen. Und jeder Zauberspruch, den man ablässt, gehen halt einige von diesen Punkten weg und regenerieren dann halt über die Zeit in der Regel. Genau wie die Hitpoints. Oder über Magie. Armour class ist auch wichtig. Das ist ein Wert, der mit 10 anfängt. Und umso niedriger er wird, umso besser ist er. Das ist sozusagen, wie gut ist man geschützt gegen Angriffe von Monstern oder magische Angriffe. Also umso weniger, umso besser an dieser Stelle. Das heißt, es gibt unterschiedliche Rüstungstypen. Man kann die an- und ablegen, man kann die ergänzen. Manche Sachen kann man übereinander tragen, manche sind magisch. Da gibt es also mannigfaltigste Variationen, die diesen Wert dann auch beeinflussen. Genau, also das sind so diese Attribute, die man hat, die im Prinzip sich so oder so ähnlicher an den meisten Rollenspielsystemen, Fantasy-Rollenspielsystemen, ja auch wieder finden.
So, ich habe das jetzt hier mal auf den Screen geholt. Das war hier mal ein bisschen...
Genau, man kann auch noch dazu sagen, diese sehr rudimentäre grafische Darstellung, die wir haben mit diesem ASCII-Zeichensatz. Da gibt es dann auch durchaus Leute, die sich darum gekümmert haben, das eben irgendwie mit so Teilsets irgendwie aufzuhübschen. Oder es gibt auch richtige grafische Interfaces dazu, zu denen ich nicht so viel sagen kann, weil ich sie selten gespielt habe, nur so von Fotos gehen habe. Aber da gibt es Leute, die sich viel Mühe gegeben haben, das so mit isometrischen Ansichten von oben und richtigen kleinen Bildchen und so versucht haben umzusetzen.
Ja, aber so ist es natürlich schöner.
Ich finde das auch, ehrlich gesagt, ich würde auch nichts anderes mehr machen wollen, aber vielleicht auch, weil ich so angefangen habe.
Also ja, unten habe ich sozusagen, sehe ich so meinen Status irgendwie, meine Eigenschaften, die für mich jetzt ausgewurfelt würden. Also ST ist dann wahrscheinlich Strength, oder?
Genau, so ist es.
Intelligence, Wisdom und Charisma.
Dann hast du noch ein Alignment, das ist so eine Art Religion. Du kannst entweder chaotisch, neutral oder lawful sein. Das hat halt bestimmte Eigenschaften in diesem Spiel. Es gibt halt zum Beispiel Monster, die entweder demgleichen oder dem entgegengesetzten angehören und dann entweder freundlich oder nicht freundlich reagieren. Es gibt Altäre, wo man halt Dinge opfern kann, aber nur auf Altären, die halt demgleichen Alignment angehören. Und es spielt in vielerlei Hinsicht eine Rolle. Es gibt Götter, man kann beten. Zum Beispiel, wenn man in absoluter Not ist, kurz vorm Verhungern oder kurz vorm Sterben, dann kann man die göttliche Hilfe erbitten. Dann natürlich auch von dem Gott, der zu diesem ent- sprechenden, entweder chaotischen oder neutralen, oder gesetzesträumen, Religion gehört.
Muss ich hier mal eine Tür öffnen, wa?
Genau, also Plus-Zeichen sind in dem default, genau, sind Türen. Türen kamen auch erst mit Hack. Also Rogue hatte...
Nur Dungeons...
.hatte keine Türen, genau. Und Türen sind halt hin und wieder auch wirklich ein strategisches Element. Also man kann die halt, die können entweder offen oder geschlossen sein, oder auch verschlossen sein, also richtig im Sinne von verriegelt, sodass man sie auch nicht einfach öffnen kann, sondern entweder halt durch Treten oder Sauberei oder eben mit einem entsprechenden Schlüssel oder Lockpick oder... Es gibt auch den Charakter, die Charakterklasse des Touristen, der hat am Anfang eine Kreditkarte dabei, damit kann man auch Türen öffnen. Der Tourist ist eh lustig, ich kann den Anfängern auch immer nur den Touristen empfehlen. Der hat auch noch andere schöne Eigenschaften, wie zum Beispiel eine Fotoausrüstung, mit der er die Monster blenden kann.
Ach so, im Sinne von empfehlen, als dass man dann dieses...
Am Anfänger, den spielt, ja. Ich hab den früher nie gespielt als Anfänger, weil mir das immer suspekt war, in meinem Teenager-Dasein, ich dachte, das passt doch da einfach nicht rein. Heutzutage wäre ich da ein bisschen pragmatischer und vielleicht auch humorvoller. Der läuft auch mit dem Hawaii-Handwrap drum. Das muss man ausziehen, bevor man in den Shop geht, weil sonst zahlt man Touristenpreise. Also du merkst schon, Tim, die Komplexität ist hoch in dem Spiel.
Jaja, deswegen reden wir ja auch darüber.
Der Tourist, die Kreditkarte, genau, praktisch, dann hat er immer genug zu essen. Dabei, was am Anfang den Leuten auch, glaube ich, mir oft passiert ist, dass man schlichtweg verhungert am Anfang. Weil man kann zwar Monster essen, aber nicht alle. Und bevor man herausgefunden hat, welche jetzt genießbar sind und welche nicht, isst man sie vielleicht lieber nicht. Und kann es einem durchaus passieren, dass man, wenn man Pech hat und nicht genug Essensrationen unterwegs findet, dass man einfach in die Verlegenheit kommt, irgendwann wird man hin und wieder ohnmächtig, fainting und dann irgendwann entweder verhungert man oder einen Monster erwischt, während man gerade dahin dämmert. Okay, ja, also Türen genau auch kann man halt durchaus auch mal benutzen, um sich auf der Flucht hinter einem zuzuschlagen und sich einzusperren oder so. Dann kann man suchen zum Beispiel mit S, Tim, wenn ich dich da gerade sehe, weil du da meinst, es geht nicht weiter. Kannst du jetzt mal 5 S drücken, dann sucht er fünfmal. Das gibt es nämlich auch, also das sozusagen versteckte Korridore sind.
Also nach dem Motto, da müsste eigentlich was sein.
Das geübte Auge, also diese Dungeon-Erstellung, ja bestimmten Algorithmen folgt, wenn man halt Tausende gesehen hat, dann weiß man so in etwa schon, wo es noch weitergehen kann.
Jetzt hat mich ein Newt gebissen.
Hau zurück.
Wo ist denn ein Newt?
Das ist das Doppelpunkt.
Ach, der Doppelpunkt. Da muss ich jetzt diagonal drauf gehen sozusagen.
Genau.
Das wäre dann ein N? Richtig. Ha, you missed the Newt.
You kill the Newt. Ich habe den Newt getötet.
Bingo, Tim. Du bist begabt.
Kann ich den auch essen?
Nein, das kleine Monster verschwindet oft. Du hast so drauf gehauen, so musst du dir das vorstellen.
Die sind dann sozusagen gesplittert und dann war es das.
Genau, sonst könnte man den essen.
Verstehe. Gibt es auch Fnords?
Ein Fnord ist mir noch nicht begegnet, aber du könntest sagen slash und dann kannst du sagen specify by name. Jetzt sagst du no.
Also nicht by cursor.
Dann kannst du mal nach Fnord, genau.
Nee, gibt es nicht.
We have no information on those things.
Das wird sozusagen, also, ja. Hier ist so ein, da ist noch so ein Apostroph.
Das ist ein Boulder. Das ist ein Stein, den könntest du, im Augenblick kannst du ihn, ja genau, den kann man schieben und bewegen. Damit kann man natürlich auch Korridore verstellen.
Ah, jetzt habe ich die Tür sozusagen zugeschoben.
Genau, richtig.
Verstehe.
Das wird, gibt es, genau, also was man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen kann, wo wir gerade dabei sind, also nicht alles im Spiel wird randommäßig generiert. Es gibt bei NetHack dann auch relativ viele Level, die halt einen festen Floorplan haben. Also alles, was darin passiert ist, immer noch Objekte und so weiter sind zufällig erschaffen, aber der Floorplan ist fix. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel auch einen Speziallevel, der Soko-Bahn heißt, wo diese Boulder eine große Rolle spielen, wo man nämlich strategisch diese Boulder hin und her schieben muss, um dort dann irgendwelche Erdlöcher mitzufüllen, die einem den Weg in den nächsten Dungeon frei machen. Fällt mir bei der Gelegenheit gerade ein. Genau, man kann auch auf den Boden schreiben. Und das ist insbesondere sinnvoll, wenn man weiß, was man da schreibt. Da gibt es zum Beispiel das magische Wort Elbereth, was man schreiben kann, was bei Monstern, die lesen können, dazu führt, dass sie einen nicht angreifen, solange wie man sich nicht bewegt. Dann kann man solche Dinge machen, wie anfangen zu schweben, indem man halt einen Ring auf Levitation hat oder sowas. Und dann kann man diesen Trick umgehen. Dann verwischt das nicht während des Kampfes das Wort darunter. Man ist immer noch immun gegen die Angriffe. Und kann dann zum Beispiel mit Fernwaffen, Pfeil und Bogen oder so weiter hinter diesem magischen Schutzschild.
Was muss ich schreiben?
Mit E? Elbereth, genau. Mit großem E. Elbereth. Das ist ein Trick. Und das ging bei Hack 100%ig. Da hatte man nicht zwischen Lesenden und Nichtlesenden und es war eigentlich ein ziemlich billiger Trick, immer gut davon zu kommen. Hier funktioniert das nicht immer. Und dieses Schreiben auf dem Boden ist... Ja gut, erzähl ich später vielleicht noch was dazu.
So, ich sehe ein Fragezeichen.
Genau, ein Fragezeichen ist das Symbol für Scrolls. Und dann siehst du auch, dass dieser Scroll einen nicht lesbaren Namen hat. Genau. Und das ist sozusagen, du müsstest den jetzt, wenn du ihn benutzen willst, oder du kannst ihn einfach benutzen und versuchen ihn darüber zu identifizieren.
Benutzen?
Ja, im Sinne von R, für Read. Du musst ihn erstmal aufnehmen.
Ah, die Katze hat mir jetzt meinen Scroll geklaut.
Genau. Das ist aber ein gutes Zeichen, weil ein positiver Effekt von deinem Haustier ist, es würde niemals verwunschen, also Cursed Objects, also jedes Objekt kann drei Stati haben, entweder es ist Blessed, im Sinne von gesegnet, heilig, es ist Cursed, im Sinne von verwunschen, oder eben kein von beiden, es hat keinen besonderen Status. Und das ist auch ein Vorteil von diesem Pet, wenn man es dabei hat, oder von allen zahmen Monstern, die man um sich gescharrt hat, dass sie eben einem Hinweise darüber gehen, ob die Objekte, die dort liegen, irgendwie...
Okay, das lese ich mal.
Ja, Fragezeichen.
Ich lese das Fragezeichen.
Du hast die noch nicht aufgenommen. Mit Komma. Genau, jetzt sagt er O, Scall, Named, Read O.
Ach so, das heißt, jedes Objekt, was ich aufnehme, kriege ich dann auch gleich so einen Buchstaben, damit ich es dann wiederum adressieren kann.
Genau, und das führt aber auch dazu, dass du nach 2x26, also klein- und Großbuchstaben, dein Inventory voll ist. Dann gibt es aber natürlich so Sachen wie, dass man Bags of Holding oder sowas haben kann. Oder Kisten oder was auch immer, in die man dann Dinge tun kann. Dann habe ich nochmal 54. Storage, genau. Aber so funktioniert das, genau.
52.
Was jetzt hier der Fall ist, ist eben genau das, was ich vorhin beschrieben habe, dass das Spiel jedes Mal sich praktisch neu initialisiert. Also man hat die Aufgabe tatsächlich, alle, zumindest alle magischen Gegenstände, Ringe, Zauberstäbe, Amulette und Sprüche, eben jedes Mal neu zu identifizieren, also die Welt zu entdecken. Für jemanden, der jetzt sozusagen komplett neu in diesem Spiel ist, der hat an diesem Falle schlecht. Also Your Hands Grow Red ist ein Indiz dafür, dass es sich dabei um einen Scroll of Confused Monster handelt. Du hast jetzt rote Hände. Wenn du das nächste Mal einen Monster angreifst, musst du sehen, dass es vor dir fliehen wird.
Aha, das heißt, die bleiben jetzt sozusagen auch?
Genau, also ich würde den jetzt, ich würde den in meinem Spiel CF nennen für Confused Monster, weil ich keine Lust habe, so viel zu schreiben. Achso, das heißt, Call of Squire, ich gebe jetzt sozusagen diesen gelesenen Zauber-Spruch. Genau, das muss man nicht immer tun, aber bei einigen muss man das machen. CF für Confused Monster, äh, CM, Entschuldige, ja, genau.
Confused Monster, CM, Tim, bitte schön. Was habe ich denn noch? Ich habe ja noch ein Uncursed Scroll of Enchant Armor.
Genau, damit kannst du deine Enchant Armor, dabei kannst du deine Rüstung um einen Punkt verbessern.
A Blessed Scroll of Teleportation.
Damit kannst du im Level, genau, hin und her teleportieren.
Und Spellbooks habe ich auch noch hier.
Genau, und damit kannst du auch, du kannst auch mal in deinen ganzen Inventory gucken, wenn du neugierig bist, mit I. Und siehst alle Gegenstände, die du so anfangst dabei hast. Der Zauberer ist relativ dankbar, weil er halt relativ viel, oftmals viele spannende Sachen von vornherein dabei hat. Im Gegensatz zum Barbaren, der halt zwar sehr stark ist, aber dann halt die Zweihandwaffe und eine Rüstung hat. Und vielleicht noch was zu beißen und das war's. Hat doch der Zauberer am Anfang relativ viel... Ringe, Potions, Spellbooks. Zeug, was man, vor allem wenn man weiß, was man tut, sinnvoll verwenden kann. Aber das ist aber relativ ausgewogen. Also ich meine, von den vielen Charakterklassen sind doch irgendwie, also... Alle haben ihre Vor- und Nachteile. Dafür ist der Wizard halt, sag mal... Kriegt schnell was auf die Ommel. Genau, Armor Class 9 ist nicht viel.
Jetzt habe ich hier schon einen gewissen Eindruck, bin aber etwas verloren, weil hier ist nur irgendwie Graffiti auf dem Floor und... Oh, eine Sewer-Red greift mich jetzt an.
Genau, die Kanalratte greift dich an.
Oh, die mache ich jetzt. Your hand stopped glowing red.
Die ist jetzt genau. Das ist die Wirkung deines Zauber, die du vorhin ausruhiert hast. Genau. Das ist vielleicht ein Nachteil von deinem Haustier, das muss auch essen.
Futtert mir deine potenzielle Rattennahrung weg.
Genau. Also es ist nicht... Aber man kann auch mit dem Tier verrückte Dinge tun. Zum Beispiel kann man es lehren, Shops auszuräubern. Also es ist zwar etwas mühsam, aber sie sind durchaus nützliche Tiere. Na, Tim, jetzt weißt du nicht, wie es weitergeht.
Nee, jetzt bin ich schon verloren.
Ja, genau. Jetzt wirst du ein klassischer Kandidat für jemanden, der als Noob wahrscheinlich ziemlich bald verhungern wird. Was ich dir vorhin gesagt habe, ist mit dem Suchen. Du kannst jetzt nach links in den Dungeon-Mauern suchen, nach einer versteckten Tür, die sich da wahrscheinlich befinden wird. Also es hat schon diese klassischen Rollenspiel-Elemente.
Man muss schon selber mitdenken, auch, um auf ein paar Ideen zu kommen.
Auf jeden Fall. Das wird auch später beliebig komplex, mit der vielen Anzahl von Gegenständen, die auch miteinander agieren kann. Also man kann Sachen in Potions dippen oder Ringe in den Abfluss werfen und dann passiert irgendwas damit. Also es gibt absurdeste Konstellationen und Kombinationen von Vorgängen, die man tun kann, miteinander kombinieren kann, um irgendwelche Effekte in dem Spieler vorzurufen. Es ist einfach wahnsinnig komplex. Es ist wahnsinnig komplex und es ist trotzdem in sich komplett, wie ich finde, konsistent. Also man hat nie das Gefühl, dass man denkt, da passiert jetzt irgendwas, was völlig unnachwurzibel ist. Und vor allen Dingen passiert halt auch immer was. Also es gab nicht umsonst diesen Spruch, The deaf team thinks of everything. Die haben wirklich an alles gedacht. Also das ist wirklich ein klassisches Zitat. Du kannst machen, was du willst. Es gibt immer irgendeine Textmeldung, irgendeine Reaktion dazu, die in dem Kontext Sinn macht. Was bei der Vielzahl der Möglichkeiten, die existieren, eine, glaube ich, eine ordentliche Leistung ist. Und was auch sehr schwierig macht, das Spiel, glaube ich, jetzt noch zu erweitern. Also seit 2003 ist ja auch keine nennenswerte neue Release mehr erschienen. Und ich habe von diesem Slasham-Leuten einen Artikel gelesen, der auch versucht hat, bestimmte Dinge zu ändern, wie sie sich verhalten. Er wollte irgendwas, es gibt solche Lava und er wollte, dass es sich mehr wie Wasser verhält. Und hat halt festgestellt, dass es sehr schwierig ist, an einer Stelle was zu ergänzen, ohne an einer anderen Stelle was zu brechen. Weil es eben dann doch relativ komplizierte Zusammenhänge zwischen den einzelnen Objekten in dem Spiel gibt und den Dingen, die man damit tun kann. Also es ist wirklich reich an Möglichkeiten, um es vorsichtig auszudrücken. Also ich spiele jetzt schon seit 20 Jahren oder so. Und denke immer noch Dinge, die ich vorher nie entdeckt habe. Und spätestens, wenn man anfängt, so Spoilerfiles zu lesen, von denen es viele gibt, wo Leute Fakten zusammen geschrieben haben, teilweise aus eigenen Erfahrungen, teilweise aus dem Sourcecode natürlich. Wo dann noch mal sehr detailliert Sachen aufgeschrieben sind, dann fasse ich mir an den Kopf und denke, was für ein Wahnsinn, das geht auch, okay. Also es gibt Spoiler, die sich nur damit beschäftigen, was man sich, es gibt die Möglichkeit, sich Objekte zu wünschen, wo sich seitenlang darüber auslassen, in welcher Reihenfolge man sich welche Objekte wünscht und wie man möglichst viele Wünsche generiert. Also dass man sich nicht, wenn man einen Wend of Wishing hat, als erstes einen Wend of Wishing wünscht, weil das haben sie natürlich ausgehebelt. Der hat dann null Wünsche, aber es gibt dann wiederum Strategien, seine Wünsche zu vermehren auf intelligente, wirklich clever Art und Weise. Also da gibt es dann mannigfaltige Möglichkeiten, sich noch Zusatzinformationen zu holen. Und ich glaube auch, das Spiel ist fast nicht schaffbar, wenn man darauf völlig verzichtet. Also behaupte ich jetzt mal. Es gibt noch andere Möglichkeiten, Erfahrungen zu machen. Zumindest wenn man im Singleplayer, also nicht auf einem Server spielt, sondern die Standardinstallation auf seinem Laptop macht, gibt es die Möglichkeit, in den sogenannten Explorer-Mode zu wechseln. Da kann man sozusagen mit Ctrl-Groß-X, oder ich glaube nur mit Groß-X, weiß ich gar nicht genau, in so eine Art Unsterblichkeitsmodus gehen. Also man stirbt, aber man wird sofort wiederbelebt. Aber man kann halt in diesem Modus nicht in die Highscore-Liste eingehen und das Spiel nicht wirklich schaffen natürlich, sondern man kann da nur versuchen, Dinge auszuprobieren, ohne sich andauernd dadurch frustrieren zu lassen, dass man wieder ganz von vorne anfangen muss.
Wenn man denn das Spiel beendet, dann muss man auch immer wieder von vorne anfangen?
Nein, das ist die Sache mit dir, Permadeath. Darüber haben wir ja gesprochen, Tim. Das ist so, wenn du tot bist, tot ist tot. Es sei denn, du bist in diesem Explorer-Mode, der dafür gemacht ist, sich in dem Spiel zu bewegen, wo man mal irgendwas ausprobieren möchte oder Erfahrungen sammeln möchte. Ich hab das selber nie gemacht. Ich glaube, es führt auch dazu, dass man, wenn man das viel macht, sich eine bestimmte Art zu spielen angewöhnt, die auch nicht sehr gesund ist, nämlich einfach solange mit dem Monster kämpft, auch wenn man eigentlich unterlegen ist, weil man ja eh immer wieder belebt wird. Und man kann natürlich das Spiel so nicht schaffen. Also man kommt nicht in den Highscore und man kriegt nicht die Möglichkeit, da irgendwie was zu erschieben.
Ich hab gelesen, dass Diablo sich an NetHack ein wenig...
Ich hab das nicht gespielt, ich hab den Leuten immer nur zugeguckt. Und auch mich mit meinen Unterhalten, die beides kennen, das muss sehr ähnlich sein. Man hat eben auch diese Möglichkeit, man hat diese Aufsicht, man hat eben unterschiedliche Waffen, man hat unterschiedliche Scrolls, Spellsysteme, man levelt, all diese Sachen sind da auch drin. Ich meine, was halt bei NetHack, was haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt, eine wichtige Eigenschaft ist, dass es turn-based ist. Man macht einen Zug, dann bewegt sich die Welt, dann macht man wieder einen Zug und ich glaube, Diablo ist eher ein Realtime-Spiel. Das heißt, man muss sich halt in Echtzeit dort bewegen.
Das ist das Schöne, man kann NetHack einfach stehen lassen und dann passiert jetzt nichts. Oder gibt es da irgendwelche Timeouts?
Nö. Vielleicht gibt es irgendwelche von deiner Terminal-Verbindung, wenn du das remote machst auf irgendwelchen Servern, dass das austimet oder so was. Aber ansonsten kann das ewig bestehen. Also es ist halt ein rundenbasiertes Spiel. Das sind diese Roguelike-Spiele, aber auch alle.
Was gibt es denn, also ich meine, kannst du so aus deiner Perspektive, wie häufig begegnest du außerhalb von NetHack Dingen, die irgendwie von NetHack stammen? Also was ist so die Beeinflussung der allgemeinen Nerd-Pop-Kultur, die man vielleicht gar nicht so bewusst wahrnimmt?
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall Dinge. Also zum Beispiel eins meiner Lieblingsprogramme, was ich auch jeden Tag benutze, ist halt Screened, was auch so ein UNIX-Programm ist, wo man halt virtuelle Terminals sich in seiner Konsole zusammenbauen kann und andere schöne Dinge tun kann. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel die Option, das im NetHack-Mode zu bedienen. Ja, dann kriegt man zum Beispiel, wenn man einen Fehler produziert, was normalerweise eine Visual-Bell oder eine Bell auslösen würde, dann gibt es halt immer so eine NetHack-entsprechende Fehlermeldung, was weiß ich, The Nude Bites oder The Jackal Hits oder sowas. Also, das gibt es durchaus.
Und so außerhalb der UNIX-Welt?
Also, ich kann nur sagen, durch das viele Spielen, gibt es natürlich auch Leute, die davon geprägt sind. Also, mir geht es manchmal so, wenn das Licht ausgeht, dann sage ich sowas wie, you are surrounded by darkness, was der Spruch ist bei NetHack, wenn man einen Cursed Scroll of Light liest, der das Licht um dich ausmacht. Also, ich glaube, es gibt auch Diskussionen in den Newsgroups darüber, was man sich im wirklichen Leben für ein NetHack-Objekt wünschen würde, wenn man sich was wünschen dürfte. Es gibt schon die Leute, die sich da in ihrem richtigen Leben, wenn man sich so viel damit beschäftigt, Einzug genommen hat. Aber an Software, lass mich mal überlegen, außer diesem Screen-Beispiel, ob mir da spontan etwas einfällt. Ich würde sagen, erstmal nicht. Vielleicht komme ich noch auf was, Tim.
Dieses Ding mit dem, also der Name NetHack, wenn man heutzutage, glaube ich, etwas entdeckt, was mit Net anfängt, also in Bezug auf ein Spiel, dann würde man natürlich erwarten, dass es auch so ein Multi-User-Viele-Leute-Spielen-Gleichzeitig-Ding ist.
Das stimmt.
So World of Warcraft, dass man da so eine große Welt hat, so ein Multi-User.
Aber das ist ja ein reines Singleplayer-Spiel. Es gibt kleine Ausnahmen. Es gibt so etwas wie eine kleine asymmetrische Multiplayer-Möglichkeit. Die ist allerdings sehr klein. Es gibt so etwas wie Bones-Levels. Es gibt mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit, wenn man stirbt an einem Level, eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass dieser Level, so wie er ist, abgespeichert wird mit allem, was darin ist, allen Monstern. Und dass, wenn dann ein anderer Spieler kommt, gibt es wiederum eine bestimmte Wahrscheinlichkeit dafür, dass, wenn man in dieses Dungeon-Level, was ich Dungeon 40 oder 35 oder was auch immer, geht, dass dieser Bones-Level geladen wird und man dann auf das sozusagen Fragment des letzten Spielers stößt. Also der ist dann da auch drinne als Ghost, wird natürlich von dem Computer gespielt. Alle Gegenstände, die er dabei hatte, sind dort als Ghost Horde sozusagen. Also das Haustier, was er hatte, ist da mit dem Namen, den er ihm gegeben hat. Und der Spieler hat natürlich auch den Namen, dieser Ghost von dem Spieler, der da war. Wenn der zum Beispiel was auf den Boden geschrieben hätte vorher, dann könnte man das lesen, ja, so wie so ein Graffiti oder sowas. Also ich gebe zu, das ist nun eine sehr, also, entfernte... Aber als ich zum Beispiel mit meinem Bruder damals viel NetHack gespielt habe, haben wir, sind wir oft über unsere eigenen Bones-Fights gestolpert. Und das war sehr lustig, weil man auf dem Atari ST auch den Spielernamen selber eingeben konnte. Bei UNIX ist das der Default-Login-Name. Und wir haben zum Beispiel dann dieselben Bücher gelesen oder so. Und dann hat man halt Charaktere genommen aus Sachen, die man kannte. Und das war oft sehr lustig. Oder seinen Tieren und welche Namen gegeben. Also das war schon so eine Interaktion, Kommunikation kann man nicht sagen. Aber es war zumindest eine extrem erheiternde Erfahrung. Und auch diese Ghost Horts waren sehr spannend, weil oft jemand dann halt bestimmte magische Waffen, die man zusammenbauen muss aus bestimmten, was weiß ich, aus einem Wurmzahn und einem Scroll of Enchant Weapon oder so, dann auf einmal da ein bestimmtes Objekt gesehen hat, was man vorher nicht kannte, und dann konnte man das a. benutzen und b. auch mal dann versuchen selbst herauszufinden, wo das herkommt. Oder ich konnte in dem Fall natürlich auch einfach meinen Bruder fragen. Aber das geht dann meistens bei den Online-Spielen natürlich.
Aber so richtig, so dass man mal gemeinsam mit mehreren in so einem Level...
Nee, es würde nicht gehen.
Es würde nicht gehen, genau. Das wäre jetzt mal eine Frage.
Nee, es würde nicht gehen, wegen diesem Turn-Based. Wie würdest du das implementieren? Das geht nicht. Nee, das ist so gesehen eine Single-Player-Experience. Auf dem Server, wo ich gerne spiele, nethack.al.org, gibt es noch ein Feature des Voyeur-Modus. Man kann sich watch games...
Warte mal, warum spielst du das auf einem Server?
Aus genau diesem Grunde, weil ich total auf diese Bones-Files stehe. Wenn du das auf Lokal spielst, hast du immer nur deine eigenen. Ich bin vielleicht eindimensional, ich weiß es nicht. Ich spiele oft ähnliche Charakterklassen, mit ähnlichem Equipment und ähnlichem Herangehenswert. Sodass ich auch immer wieder mehr oder weniger dasselbe Zeug da finde. Aber wenn du halt eine große... Was sagt man? Variety? Auswahl. Also viele Leute hast du hier auf diesen Hunderten und Tausende von Leuten, die da spielen. Es ist spannender einfach dort auch in deren Überresten zu warten sozusagen.
Ja, okay, verstehe. Also das macht so einen großen Unterschied.
Für mich jetzt. Es gibt Leute, denen das total...
Sturz ist.
Ja, genau. Also für mich ist das irgendwie ein Highlight.
Als Spiele-Deb habe ich es ein bisschen schwer da jetzt gut zu fragen, aber was ich mich frage, ist natürlich diese Komplexität und diese Varietät im Spielablauf, die du ja hier so beschwörst. Im Vergleich zu dem, was man heutzutage aus Spielen so erwarten kann an Komplexität. Ist das jetzt sozusagen nur deshalb so beeindruckend, weil man nur so wenige Kilobyte runterlädt, wenn man dieses Spiel startet und das ist sozusagen für diese reduzierte Terminal-Welt und den Single-User-Modus komplex? Oder ist das auch im Vergleich zu Games heutzutage, ich meine auch World of Warcraft ist ja ein riesiger Reichtum und so weiter.
Das ist sicherlich, okay, das will ich keine Aussage zu machen, das ist sicherlich vergleichbar, wobei ich das nicht gespielt habe. Aber dadurch, dass natürlich auch da Menschen miteinander interagieren.
Da passiert einfach viel, weil viele Leute da sind.
Genau.
Aber jetzt so rein von den Spiel-Ideen und der Art und Weise, wie man Dinge lösen muss, das meine ich jetzt.
Würde ich sagen, das ist, würde ich sagen, immer noch beeindruckend. Und wahrscheinlich auch, ich würde sagen, mir fällt spontan nichts ein, was den irgendwie ähnlichen Grad an Komplexität hat. Ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch nicht zeitgängig, so würde man heute auch nicht mehr machen. Das Frustrationspotenzial ist, glaube ich, auch hoch in diesem Spiel. Also es kann einfach auch sein, dass man auch nach Stunden des Spiels durch irgendeinen blöden Fehler da stirbt und dann wieder von vorne anfangen muss. Das würde heute wahrscheinlich keiner mehr machen. Ich meine, da muss ich überlegen, die Leute haben das über so 15 Jahre oder so 14 Jahre halt entwickelt. Nur in ihrer Freizeit, nur zu ihrem Spaßverdienung. Die haben dann natürlich da auch eine andere Liebe und Leidenschaft reingesteckt. Das würde wahrscheinlich heute bei einer kommerziellen Spieleentwicklung so nicht passieren. Ich weiß nicht genau, vielleicht gibt es... Ich will mich da jetzt nicht so weit rauslehnen. Also vielleicht gibt es ja auch diese Mats zum Beispiel, wo viele Leute Tausende von Quests rein programmiert haben. Das geht ja eher wieder an diese Text-Adventure-Geschichte, was in einer Art von Spiel ist, aber die natürlich auch extrem viele Möglichkeiten gewonnen haben. Aber ich würde sagen, also das ist immer noch, ich würde sagen, es steht dem auf jeden Fall in nichts nach. Ich würde vielleicht sogar sagen, es ist auf jeden Fall in dem Sinne total zeitgemäß mehr drin, als man entdecken kann.
Also wer sozusagen drauf steht, auf diese Komplexität, wie lange kann man sich damit aufhalten? Also wie lange dauert denn so ein Spiel? Naja, also ich meine, bei mir wahrscheinlich nicht lange.
Ich muss ja jetzt auch gestehen, dass ich, ich habe damals Hack mal durchgespielt, also ich bin da in die astralen Ebenen, in die Astral Plane aufgestiegen. Das war auch einfach wirklich, muss man sagen. In NetHack ist mir das nicht gelungen. Also ich bin jetzt auch nicht jemand, der so viel diese Spoiler liest oder sich wirklich, ich versuche das so ein bisschen, das ist mein Ehrgeiz auch, wobei ich langsam an den Punkt komme, wo ich auch da aufgebe, glaube ich.
Wann ist dieser Punkt erreicht? Also du startest jetzt ein Spiel, wie lange? Also wie lange jetzt?
Ein ganzes Spiel dauert, bis man es durch...
Also es gibt...
Ich hab letztens geguckt, ich hab's ja noch nicht geguckt, ich hab letztens geguckt, es gibt dieses alljährliche Tournament bei einer Webseite, die nethackdev0.net heißt. Die machen immer zu Halloween eine große, weltweite NetHack-Challenge, wo man sich anmelden kann, das geht dann ein paar Tage. Und in dieser Spielzeit kann man auf mehreren NetHack-Servern gegen alle Spieler dieser Welt antreten und mit denen sozusagen konkurrieren. Und da gibt es auch natürlich eine Challenge, wer kommt am schnellsten runter, Amulett, und kann als Demigod in die Astral Plane aufsteigen und...
Wie viele Level muss man da überspringen?
Das ist auch ein bisschen randommäßig, also es gibt so bestimmte Ranges, es gibt die Dungeons of Doom, den ersten Teil sozusagen mit unterschiedlichen Subleveln, jeder Charakter hat nochmal eine extra Charakter-Quest, die auch nochmal so zwischen vielleicht 5 und 7 Level umfasst. Es gibt diese Speziallevel wie den Sokoban, also danach kommt das Maze of Menace, was dann auf das Endspiel zugeht, mit nochmal vielen Spezialleveln, Valley of Death und... Also da gibt es dann nochmal den Tower vom Wizard und so weiter. Also es sind, ich würde sagen, roundabout zwischen 40 und 50 Level. So in der Größenordnung. Sag ich, muss man durchspielen. Das ist vielleicht doch ein bisschen mehr, aber so in der Größenordnung.
Und wie lange braucht man dafür?
Na ich wollte sagen, also einer dieser Challenges ist, also wer am schnellsten rein und wieder rauskommt, dann gibt es Leute, die das so, ich glaube, so in drei Stunden schaffen. Ich frage mich, wie die das machen, aber es sind dann auch die schnellsten der Welt. Und es gibt auch Leute, die das halt...
Ja.
Das würde ewig dauern. Also es kommt ja auch...
Also abgesehen davon, dass du dann noch gar nicht hingekommen bist.
Genau. Und dass ich auch das halt auch selten in einem Stück spiele, sondern ich speichere dann irgendwann ab, auch allein schon, weil ich dann irgendwann zu faserig werde und dann den schnellen Tod der Unaufmerksamkeit sterben könnte.
Aber jetzt so angenommen, du würdest alle deine Spielzüge mehr oder weniger entspannt hintereinander...
Ich kann es nur extrapolieren und hochrechnen.
Dann reden wir jetzt von Tagen, Wochen...
Ja, ich würde sagen, ja, ich denke mal, ich würde schätzen acht bis zwölf Stunden. Ich könnte mal meinen Bruder, der es schon mehrmals geschafft hat, fragen, wie lange er gespielt hat, habe ich leider nicht, aber ich denke mal, ich würde das auch schätzen. Also ich würde so lange brauchen. Es gibt auch, wie gesagt, in diesem NetHack-Server, wo man sich mit Tänern darauf connecten kann und spielen kann auch diesen Voyeur-Mode, wo man Leuten zugucken kann beim Spielen. Und es gibt Leute, die wirklich...
Können wir das jetzt machen?
Können wir machen, du kannst ja mal sagen...
Wo muss ich denn da hin?
Du kannst mal telnet.nethack.ald.org sagen.
telnet.nethack.ald.org Ja, genau.
So, und jetzt kannst du mal login, dann kannst du meinen Namen nehmen. Und mein Passwort. Wenn ich jetzt die Mute-Taste drücke, dann kann keiner hören. Was? Wenn ich jetzt die...
Du tippst das hier einfach mal kurz und entspannt ein.
Genau, das ist auch kein sehr spannendes Passwort für mich.
So, muss ich erstmal da einloggen.
Achso, hast du schon meinen Namen?
Nein, nein, ich hab noch nichts getan. Wir machen das jetzt hier alles live und in Farbe und betreten jetzt hier The Dungeon of the Server.
Watch Games in Progress. Du siehst, es spielen jetzt gerade zwölf Leute. Und dann kannst du unten hinten ist sozusagen der Dungeon-Level. Wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel mal hier die F nimmst. Focopedia. Wäre ein Kandidat für einen... Wäre ein Kandidat für einen...
Ach, das ist ja geil. Ach, das ist ja wirklich...
Da kann man auch viel lernen, by the way.
Aber was für ein geiler... Also das hätte ich ja gerne als Screensaver hätte ich das ja gerne. Irgendwie das... Na ja, mal eine Anmeldung, ne? Also man kann jetzt hier sozusagen wirklich... Welchen Level befindet sich Dungeon-Level?
Level 8. Also das ist auch jetzt nicht... Aber man sieht ja oft Leute, deswegen habe ich das so erwähnt, die da mit einer atemberaubenden Geschwindigkeit... Also die das auch wirklich nicht mehr... Also man kann ja NetHack spielen, als würde man vielleicht ein Buch lesen gegenüber... Als würde man einen Film sehen, also man kann versuchen, sich die Dinge vorzustellen, die Situation, die Monsterbeschreibungen lesen und das sozusagen mit Kopfkino irgendwie genießen.
Kann sich da jeder einen Account machen? Also das, was du da jetzt gerade gemacht hast?
Da kann sich jeder einen Account machen, klar.
Das ist ja wirklich fancy.
Das freut mich, dass sich das freut, Tim.
Ja, das freut mich total. Ich meine, das wäre mal ein Top-Screensaver. Also da hätte ich jetzt gerne mal so ein Screensaver-Modul, was mir automatisch immer so eine Live-Nethack-Session direkt auf dem Bildschirm zaubert. Gibt es bestimmt schon irgendwo, aber habe ich jetzt noch nichts von gehört, wäre auf jeden Fall cool, müsste man natürlich so ein bisschen diesen Zugang da automatisieren. Aber jetzt kann man mal wirklich so sehen, wie so richtige Profis hier...
Ja, wobei das jetzt hier kein... Ich hätte mir mehr erwartet. Also es gibt da durchaus Leute, wo man... Also ich mache das auch manchmal zum Spaß, dass ich da einfach zugucke, wo man wirklich mit den Ohren schlage. Es gibt halt auch Key-Commandos, mit denen man dann nicht mehr den Weg gehen muss im Dungeon, sondern man geht bloß noch den Zielort an. Und dann gibt es halt so eine Routing-Algorithmus, die dich auf dem kürzesten Weg da hinführt. Wenn man das exzessiv benutzt und die entsprechenden Tastenkürzel kennt, um halt bestimmte Punkte anzuspringen, zum Beispiel die Treppenaufgänge nach oben und unten, kann man sich da extrem schnell...
Aber das ist ja schon ganz fancy Rendering, weil hier werden ja nicht nur die normalen ASCII-Zeichen für uns gemalt.
Genau, wir hatten einen bestimmten Font einfach. Da gibt es einen bestimmten Font, den man einstellen kann. Und dann werden halt diese...
Umrandungen, sozusagen, als richtige Linien gemalt.
Genau. Und das ist auch noch eine ganz schöne Erweiterung. Also es ist ja auch... Ansonsten ist da auch nichts geändert. Das sind immer noch die normalen ASCII-Zeichen für die Objekte. Aber die Dungeon-Render sind einfach nicht... sind einfach geschlossene Linien, genau.
Lustig, hier wird irgendwie fleißig gegen Pythons gekämpft. The giant spider bite was poisoned. Oha, hier geht es aber jetzt richtig ab. Aber auch die Spider musst du auch dran glauben. Oh man, das kann ich hier echt jedem nur empfehlen. Das ist ja wirklich geiles Kopfkino.
Ja, bitte. Ich würde auch nur noch mal sagen, dass es halt auch oft, also wenn man sich für das Spiel interessiert, auch oft lehrreich ist. Also man kann ja, da sind immer, gestern Nacht habe ich mal geguckt, weil ich auch mal wissen wollte, ich dachte vielleicht kommt die Frage, wie beliebt ist das Spiel eigentlich noch? Spielt es überhaupt noch jemand? Und da selber habe ich das mal so ein bisschen die letzten Tage mal empirisch erforscht, auf diesem Server, ob da eigentlich immer jemand spielt zum Beispiel. Und da sind, also gestern waren da nachts 21, 22, 30 Leute irgendwie. Also es wird schon anscheinend, und ich denke es gibt sicher noch mehr NetHack-Server im Internet. Also es ist der erste, den ich damals gefunden habe, wo ich dann gespielt habe.
Dieser Modus, das man zugucken kann, ist das mittlerweile Bestandteil der Software?
Nein, das haben sie da reingehackt. Ich weiß nicht, inwiefern, das kann man glaube ich auch danach lesen, inwiefern die das... Die sind auch super nett. Also zum Beispiel passiert manchmal, dass wenn die Terminal-Verbindung abbricht, dass das Spiel kaputt geht, dass es nicht richtig recovert. Und dann gibt es extra ein Tool zu NetHack, was in der Lage ist, die wieder unter Umständen zusammenzubauen. Und dann habe ich ihm eine Mail geschrieben, ob er mal gucken kann, ob bei einem Spiel, weil ich da schon Stunden und Tage dran war. Und dann habe ich ihm eine Mail geschrieben, und dann gibt es auch Service. Ich dachte, wir hätten ihn jetzt zu sehr hypen.
Genau. Was ich ja sehr mag an diesem ganzen Ding, also ich meine, es ist natürlich erstmal super nerdy, gerade dieses total minimierte User-Interface. Aber was sich hier, glaube ich, sehr schön zeigt, ist generell erstmal so die große Spiele-Begeistertheit, oder sagen wir mal dieses spielerische, weißt du, dieses, im besten Wort so eine kindische, was ja diese ganze Computerkultur eigentlich aus meinem Blickwinkel auf jeden Fall immer begleitet hat, das ist irgendwie bei NetHack irgendwie in Code gegossen. Also so bis hin zu diesen Finessen, die wir ja auch schon gehabt hatten, so mit dieser Integration mit dem Betriebssystem, dass dann auf einmal in deinem Spiel auch noch deine Mail zugestellt wird, da bin ich wirklich komplett aus den Puschen gefallen.
Was passiert jetzt?
Wie viele Tage gebraucht ist, das ist immer wunderbar. Das war so eine großartige Idee und dann auch immer noch so wunderbar umgesetzt.
Und auch eigentlich so naheliegend, ja, wenn man halt jetzt die ganze Zeit an seinem, gerade damals hatte man ja nur ein Terminal und man hat halt waren sein Spiel versunken, war natürlich auch, glaube ich, ganz praktisch, dass wenn man dann...
Ja, man wollte seine Mail nicht verpassen, ja.
Genau, also das war, hatte auch total, sagen wir mal, seine Berechtigung davor. Aber von abgesehen, dass es auch schön gemacht ist natürlich.
Was ich damit sagen will, ist, dass, glaube ich, über diese Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Spiel hier, dass ja, also einerseits hat man ein Spiel, ja, man hat sozusagen eine Beschäftigung und kann sich hier auch relativ komplexen Problemen aussetzen und mal versuchen, da seinen Hirn dran zu schleifen. Aber man lernt halt eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge darüber, wie so diese ganze Szene auch an der Stelle gestrickt ist.
Ja, ich glaube ich auch durchaus. Also ich habe auch sozusagen so ein bisschen, man kriegt so ein Gefühl, also so ein bisschen für die UNIX, also damals auch diese Sache, zum Beispiel was wir hatten mit den Keybindings und so weiter. Also das war dann schon, ich hatte das Spiel erst gespielt und dann wie Eil gelernt und bestimmte Sachen waren mir dann......
sofort vertraut.
Genau, waren mir gegenwärtig, also das kann man schon sagen. Aber das ist natürlich auch vielleicht einfach aus diesem Kontext, es kommt halt alles aus diesem UNIX-Kontext, das kommt halt alles aus einem Urschleim sozusagen. Also das ist aber nicht so verwunderlich, dass es da immer wieder Parallelen gibt.
Gibt es da noch andere Events, jetzt außer dem, was du da schon genannt hast, diese NetHack-Competition?
Das ist das Einzige, wovon ich weiß. Das wurde auch immer auf Slashdot gefeatured vorher, dass man das nicht verpasst. Ich habe aber auch selber nur einmal...
Kann man da auch so live zugucken?
Bin ich nicht sicher, ehrlich gesagt. Die geben sich auch relativ viel Mühe, Infrastruktur drumherum zu bauen, mit verteilten Servern und dann hast du eine User-Datenbank, die sie irgendwo pflegen müssen, weil da halt auf allen Servern und dann halt die Highscore-Listen merken. Da gibt es dann auch entsprechend verrückte Competitions, die sich selbst einfallen lassen. Zum Beispiel, wer auf die unterschiedlichsten Arten, also meisten unterschiedlichen Arten, stirbt. Also man kann auf kolossal verrückte Art und Weise dieses Spiel verlassen. Und es ist eine Challenge. Du kannst natürlich so banal, du kannst irgendwie verhungern, ertrinken von Monster XY, du kannst aber auch, was ich dir, den Kopf an der Decke stoßen und daran sterben oder bei dem Versuch, eine Kiste aufzutreten oder bei dem Versuch, einen Cockatrice in eine Konservendose zu tun. Das ist ein Monster, was dich zu steinen werden lässt, wenn du es berührst. Es gibt immer am Ende, in der Highscore-Liste gibt es einen kurzen Satz, der darüber Auskunft gibt, wie du aus dem Spiel geschieden bist. Du kannst irgendwie unter dem Einfluss von Halluzinogenen, Drogen, von einem One-Eyed, One-Horned, Flying Purple People Eater gegessen worden sein. Es gibt die beknacktesten Sachen. Das haben die auch zu einer Competition gemacht. Du kannst einfach dahin gehen und versuchen, so oft wie möglich zu failen, aber bitte auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise. Also, es ist schon sehr lustig. Es gibt wirklich diverseste... In dem Handbuch steht ja auch, nicht, dass es schon schlimm genug wäre, das Spiel überhaupt schaffen zu können, also, dass es sehr schwer ist, sondern es gibt auch noch beliebige Verfeinerung von der Idee, es überhaupt zu schaffen. Auch bei dieser Competition ist es so, dass man für alle möglichen Charakterklassen, also als Rogue, als Wizard, als Priest und so weiter, einzeln abgehandelt wird. Oder es gibt da halt so Challenges, wo man versucht, als Vegetarier oder als Veganer, also halt keine Monster essen oder eben gar nicht essen oder als Pazifist zum Beispiel. Also, als mir das erste Mal jemand erzählt hat, er versucht als Pazifist NetHack durchzuspielen, denkt man an der ersten Sekunde, ey, das Spiel geht nur darum, Monster zu töten.
Als Pazifist jetzt als Rolle, die man wirklich wählen kann?
Nee, sondern das ist eine Selbst... Also, niemand töten. Genau. Niemand töten, genau. Und wenn man aber dann das Spiel kennt und eine Sekunde noch darüber nachdenkt, fallen einem auf einmal Dinge ein, wie das natürlich möglich ist, das zu schaffen, ohne jemand zu töten. Obwohl man ja am Ende den Wizard auf jeden Fall töten muss. Aber es gibt natürlich die Möglichkeit...
Das ist dann die einzige Ausnahme, sozusagen, oder?
Nee, es gibt keine Ausnahmen. Sondern es gibt die Möglichkeit halt... Man kann ja Monster zähmen. Man hat ja zum Beispiel am Anfang ein Pet. Wenn man genügend mächtige Monster um sich scharrt...
Ach, dann lässt man die Monster?
Oder es gibt zum Beispiel so etwas wie den Ring auf Konflikt, der dafür sorgt, dass alle Monster, die in Sichtweite sind, anfangen, sich gegenseitig zu bekämpfen. Also man kann schon, wenn man ein bisschen das Spiel kennt...
So ein bisschen der diskordische Ansatz, so alle verwirren.
Oder man kann einschläfern und so was. Also es gibt alles Mögliche, um dem zu entgehen, die wirklich zu finishen. Also es ist auch so ein Beispiel, wo man auch so dieses... Wie soll das gehen? Und dann denkt man kurz nach, naja, das geht und das und das. Und das geht wahrscheinlich auch. Und das. Und dann merkt man auch wieder, wie das alles irgendwie ineinandergreift und eben viele Sachen möglich sind. Einige von diesen Challenges werden auch tatsächlich vom Spiel erkannt. Also man kann zum Beispiel als Atheist zum Beispiel, ohne zu beten, das wird am Ende dann tatsächlich auch bemerkt von dem Spiel, dass man nullmal gebetet hat oder also schon selbst auferlegte Challenges, die man...
Was hilft dir das Beten?
Das ist oft das Mittel der letzten Wahl. Also wenn du wirklich kurz vorm Verhungern bist oder nur noch einen Hitpoint hast und der Drache oder du von Drachen umringt bist oder zum Beispiel auch Klassiker, was weiß ich, irgendeine Wehrkreatur hat dich gebissen und du verwandelt dich dann andauernd in eine Wehrratte oder einen Wehrwolf, was extrem lästig ist, weil du...
Ach so, man wird gebissen und man wird selber zu einem Tier.
Genau, das kann passieren. Also bei diesen Wehrkreaturen, die werden dann periodisch. Und das Loswerden wird, da gibt es natürlich andere Möglichkeiten, aber mal schnell Stoßgebet, wenn dir der Gott gut gesonnen ist, ist es auf jeden Fall eine softe Methode, sich aus der Affäre zu gehen.
Ach so, der Gott ist ja sozusagen so eine Art Zufallszahlengenerator.
Der ist kein Zufallszahlengenerator, der ist wohlgesonnen, der kann, du kannst mit deinem Gott per du oder sein sozusagen, je nachdem, wie du dir so spielst, ob du ihm gefällig spielst oder nicht, oder eben nicht, dann kannst du auf seine Hilfe auch nicht rechnen, im ganzen Gegenteil, dann kann es passieren, dass wenn du betest, er dich noch mit einem Blitzschlag irgendwie bestraft.
Also dieser Gott ist sozusagen dann auch immer noch ein bisschen mit dabei.
Der ist dabei, es sei denn, man kann natürlich, wie gesagt, mit atheistischem Ansatz spielen und sagen, ich brauch den nicht. Hier, Gott, my ass. Ich brauch dich nicht. Das ist wie gesagt, das wäre zum Beispiel eine von diesen Möglichkeiten, das Spiel selbst noch schwieriger zu machen, sich selbst noch Dinge aufzuerlegen, um es noch spannender, interessanter zu machen.
Was gibt es denn sonst noch so für? Ich hab jetzt gerade keine Lust, diese Sendung zu beenden, ohne von irgendeinem großartigen weiteren lustigen Detail.
Es gibt zum Beispiel die theoretische Diskussion darüber, ob es möglich ist, unendlich im Dungeon zu überleben. Also, ob es möglich ist, für ewige Zeit, also die eigentliche Idee ist ja dann irgendwann wieder, den Dungeon zu verlassen und in die Astral-Ebene aufzusteigen. Aber es gibt Leute, die sich ernsthaft Gedanken gemacht haben, ob es denn möglich sei, ewig dort unten zu bleiben, ohne zu verhungern und ohne von Monstern gefressen zu werden. Und da gab es tatsächlich dann solche Ideen, also Sachen, die natürlich auch jenseits meiner irgendwie, also es gab Leute, die dann Strategien haben. Also man verliert immer ein bisschen Energie durch einfach da sein, also im Sinne von, wie sagt man...
Pro Existenz, einfach der Basisverbrauch.
Genau, also was dann zu Hunger führt und so weiter. Es gibt dann halt Ringe, die die Verdauung verlangsamen und so was. Dann kann man sich zwei davon an jeder Hand setzen und dann kann man sich mit Steinmauern umgeben, unter denen spezielle Monster platziert sind, sodass es nicht möglich ist, dass irgendein Monster durch die Steine dringt, weil sie nicht gleichzeitig da sein können und das Monster da ist. Also komplizierteste Verfahren, die angeblich dazu führen, dass man, ich meine, niemand macht das natürlich.
Ja, aber wie platziert man den Monster? Die muss man dann irgendwie auch mit irgendeinem Zauberspruch wieder für sich einnehmen oder was?
Es gibt die Möglichkeit, halt den Scroll of Genocide, mit dem man ganze Monsterklassen ausradieren kann. Das ist auch noch so eine Challenge, ohne zu genociden zum Beispiel. Das ist auch eine Sache, die sie vor dem Spiegel gemacht hat. Und wenn man da den Curse Scroll hat, dann passiert das Gegenteil. Dann wird der Level bevölkert mit diesem Monster. Damit kann man das zum Beispiel erreichen.
Aber die sind dann doch erst mal gegen einen.
Ja, aber in diesem Fall ist das fast irgendein Slime-Mode. Also irgendein Monster, das sich nicht bewegt und einfach nur da ist, glaube ich. Und unter Steinen existieren kann wahrscheinlich. Und dann ist dadurch gewährleistet, dass du so eine Art Schutzmauer um dich heraufgebaut hast, die sozusagen...
Weil der Platz besetzt ist.
Weil der Platz besetzt ist durch den Stein. Es gibt Monster, die halt durch den Stein durchgehen können. Aber wenn da schon dieser grüne Schleim drunter ist, dann lässt das Spiel das nicht zu, dass beides geht. Und dann hat man sich schon mal vor dieser Gefahr, dass man von irgendwas totgehauen wird. Dann hat man auch das Problem, dass man hungert. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich löst bei uns. Es gibt die Leute, die sich da auch auf einem sehr theoretischen Level beschäftigen. Ja, offensichtlich. Aber das ist, glaube ich, schon so ziemlich der Gipfel von dem, was ich mir so angelesen habe.
Ja, aber wir können das Spiel weiter empfehlen. Du kannst es weiter empfehlen.
Ich kann es nur unter dem Vorbehalt, dass es, wenn man erstmal in dem Stadium ist, dass ich halt wirklich wahrscheinlich Monate meines Lebens darin verbracht habe. Also wenn man sich davor nicht scheut, würde ich es weiter empfehlen, auf jeden Fall. Natürlich.
Es soll ja so Leute geben, die durchaus mal ein bisschen bereit sind, etwas Zeit zu investieren.
Es gibt auch Leute, die...
Aber es ist ja jetzt nicht nur Zeitverschwendung, sondern üblicherweise schärft man ja eigentlich an solchen Spielen auch enorm seine Beharrlichkeit. Also ich würde sogar fast sagen, das ist sozusagen Hackerfutter insofern, als dass man lernt, sich einfach nicht... Dass man lernt, nicht früh aufzugeben.
Das stimmt.
Und auch komplexe Lösungen zu akzeptieren und dann auch entsprechend zu suchen.
Genau. Also da kann man auf jeden Fall seine Hartnäckigkeit deutlich schärfen an diesem Spiel. Und es ist natürlich auch einfach eine... Also, Recreation ist ja wirklich eigentlich eine... Also, mir hilft es oft, um einfach auch abzuschalten. Weil wenn man es halt einigermaßen spielen kann, kann man es auch auf so eine meditative Art im Prinzip schon fast spielen. Aber ja, es gibt auch natürlich Leute, die sich... Ich kenne auch viele Freunde von mir, die damals viel Rollenspiel gespielt haben und die an NetHack nie rangekommen sind. Auch die auch berechtigte Kritik haben. Also zum Beispiel diese... Es gibt durchaus die Fälle gerade am Anfang, wo man den Tod nicht verhindern kann, egal wie man sich anstellt. Also man macht eine Kiste auf, die ist irgendwie mit einer magischen Falle versehen und dann wird man halt mit dem Elektroschock erwischt und man ist dann tot. Also obwohl man... Das Spiel ist nicht immer fair, würde ich damit sagen. Also man hat keine Möglichkeit, durchsuchen oder examen oder irgendwas vorher rauszufinden, was da ist. Und man ist auch darauf angewiesen, bestimmte Dinge einfach zu tun, weil man sonst eben nicht spielen kann. Also es gibt...
Es gibt schon Dead-Ends sozusagen.
Ja, genau. Also das gibt es auch, wo ich dann auch nie sagen konnte, ja, das stimmt nicht oder so. Also das ist einfach schon natürlich...
Denkst du, das war Absicht? Ist das sozusagen so, dass das Spiel auch gar nicht will, dass man immer gewinnen kann?
Dass die Wellerball-Team hat an alles gedacht, Tim. Das war natürlich Absicht. Also ich glaube, da ist nichts Zufall.
Ein perfektes System?
Zumindestens würde ich mal sagen, in vielerlei Hinsicht. Zum Beispiel habe ich auch nie Abstürze oder Ähnliches erlebt. Also es ist wirklich... Es ist nicht richtig bugfrei. Man kann sich so Bugreports angucken, aber die sind glaube ich... Ob das wirkliche Bugs sind, sind dann vielleicht mehr so in der Spielelogik Fehler. Aber ich habe wirklich nie... Also mir ist es nie passiert, dass es abgestürzt ist oder dass irgendwas Kurioses geschehen ist.
Es ist gut abgehangen.
Es ist sehr gut abgehangen. Ich habe lange daran herumgehackt. Kann man sagen.
Kann man sagen. So wünscht man sich Software. Gut abgehangen, fehlerfrei.
Aber die haben das ja auch alle wirklich.
Aber mir haben alle alles gedacht. Wo hat man das heutzutage noch?
Ja, ich meine, das ist vielleicht auch der Benefit, den man hat, wenn man die Leute dafür bezahlt, die Dinge zu tun. Ich meine, die haben das ja alle gemacht, weil sie Bock drauf haben. Das macht, glaube ich, in der Qualität oft einen Unterschied.
Das ist eigentlich immer das Beste, ja.
Ja.
Das haben wir ein schön lang......gesprochen, ne? Ist ja auch ein interessantes Thema.
Wir haben noch nicht mal annähernd, also ich meine...
Ja, das befürchte ich gerade. Haben wir denn noch irgendwas... Also ich meine, gibt es ja noch einen Aspekt, der jetzt... Wo es geradezu eine Schande wäre, wenn wir den jetzt ausgelassen hätten.
Ich gehe hier mal ganz kurz. Ich glaube, wir haben eigentlich schon einen großen Teil...
Den Rest muss man dann vielleicht auch selbst finden.
Erfahren, genau. Einfach spielen.
Ja, einfach mal spielen.
Nee, ich glaube auch, wir hatten...
NetHack installieren gibt es auch auf allen Plattformen, nicht wahr? Das war ja nicht mehr damals so, sondern heutzutage...
Genau, gibt es auf allen Plattformen und gibt es auch sicherlich auf allen Plattformen als Spiel-Distribution.
Beziehungsweise das Beste ist eigentlich sogar auf dem Server spielen.
und Nachteile. Also zum Beispiel die Sache mit dem Explorer-Mode, zum Beispiel, ist auf vielen Servern nicht möglich. Weiß nicht, ob es jetzt da geht oder so, aber das geht oft nicht, wenn man das machen möchte. Dann das mit den Bone-Fights ist eigentlich eher ein Vorteil. Man kann, wenn man zu Hause spielt, nicht, dass ich irgendjemanden dazu ermutigen möchte, aber man kann natürlich theoretisch cheaten, wenn man das System selber hat. Weil man das Spiel safen kann und seinen Spielstand wegsichert. Es gibt auch so ein Fortune Cookie-System in NetHack, den ich dann immer gerne zitiere. Der heißt so in etwa, a winner never quits and a quitter never wins. Ach nee, a cheater never wins, genau. Also sozusagen, es ist so, man macht es nicht.
Manche Cookie-Systems kann man jetzt auch im Spiel finden.
Genau, das ist ein Lebensmittel, hat nicht sehr viel Nährwert, aber ist immer ein Spruch drinnen. Viele sind irreführend, manche sind hilfreich. Aber ich würde mich nie darauf verlassen, was da drin steht. Aber es gibt ein Orake, etwa inzwischen Level 5 und Level 8 oder Level 9. Dem kann man Geld geben und dann, wenn es genug ist, gibt es auch eine Hintliste von Hints, die gültig sind und auch Sinn machen, die man sich dann erkaufen kann. Na gut, also es gibt...
Das mit dem Kaufen haben wir noch gar nicht so richtig...
Geld, Shops, ja. Ich meine, wir haben so viele Sachen nicht... Ja, ich finde das durchaus wertvoll, weil...
Also soweit ich mich erinnere, taucht das ja relativ früh auf, dass man auf Shops stößt und da dann alles Mögliche erwerben kann.
Genau, da gibt es halt dann Shops gesortiert nach Gegenständen. Also es gibt so etwas wie ein Juwelier, der halt Ringe und Amulette verkauft. Es gibt so etwas wie eine Waffenhandlung, wo man Rüstungen und Waffen erstehen kann. Es gibt Gemischtwaren-Laden, Läden, die alles verkaufen. Es gibt Geschäfte für Zauberei. Also es ist erst mal danach sortiert. Dann gibt es halt immer einen Shopkeeper. Das sind Menschen, relativ mächtig. Es gibt natürlich immer die Versuchung, den zu bestehen. Und es gibt auch interessante Strategien, das zu tun. Erfolgreich oder nicht so erfolgreich. Wenn man mächtig genug ist, kann man sich vielleicht auch leisten, sich dem Kampf mit dem Shopkeeper zu stellen. Der holt dann allerdings oft die Keystone-Cops, die einem dann noch Torten ins Gesicht werfen und einen damit blind machen. Und man kann dann das Handtuch rausholen und sich das Gewicht abwischen, wie man es hat und so. Es wird echt beliebig, merkwürdig dann. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine Challenge. Und es ist auch eine sehr schöne Challenge. Aber man kann natürlich auch einfach genug Geld sammeln und die Dinge bezahlen. Oder man kann auch Gegenstände sammeln und Gegenstände verkaufen. Also es ist, Interaktion mit dem Shopkeeper ist auf vielerlei Weise möglich. Man kann, wie gesagt, auch seinen Pet trainieren, dass es den Shop für einen ausräubert, ohne dass der Shopkeeper was dagegen macht. Indem man irgendwie an einer bestimmten Stelle im Shop, nämlich dem ersten Feld, was man betritt, das gehört noch nicht zum Shop, dem Tier, wenn es da was ablegt zufällig, was zu essen hinschmeißt, das lernt dann, aha, wenn ich da was ablege, dann kriege ich was zu beißen. Und wenn man das drei, vier Mal hintereinander gemacht hat, funktioniert das so gut, dass man sich getrost dahinstellen kann und einfach das Tier die Dirty Work machen lassen kann. Also sich rausteleportieren, rausgraben, den Shopkeeper polymorphen, man kann echt die wahnsinnigsten Dinge tun. Aber man sei gewarnt, wenn es schief geht, kann es ganz schön aufs Auge gehen.
Der wird dann ein bisschen grantig.
Der wird dann sehr unangenehm, der ist ziemlich mächtig, der hat meistens dann auch Zauber, irgendwelche Wands auf Magic Missile und ähnlich gefährliche Dinge, mit denen er einen dann heimsucht. Und der verfolgt einen auch überall. Wenn man dann flieht in den unteren, in den nächsten Dungeon, verfolgt er einen auch gerne mal. Also den wird man auch nicht so schnell los, das kann ganz unangenehm sein.
Was heißt polymorphen?
Polymorphen heißt, man kann im Prinzip alles und jedes in seiner Form verwandeln. Also man kann sich in einen, also in einen Monster, zum Beispiel, in ein beliebiges Monster verwandeln. Wenn man, es gibt Polymorph-Control als Eigenschaft, dann kann man das wirklich aussuchen, was extrem mächtig ist. Also dann kannst du dich halt, keine Ahnung, in einen fliegenden Drachen verwandeln und feuerspucken oder was auch immer gerade gut ist. Du kannst dich in einen, sehr beliebt in einen Rustmonster, in einen Rustmonster verwandeln. Das kann dann Metall essen. Und wenn man zum Beispiel seine Ringe und so weiter, wenn man die alle isst, es gibt immer, glaube ich, eine Einviertelwahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Eigenschaft des Rings auf das Monster übergeht, wenn es den Ring ist. Sodass, wenn man sich dann zurückverwandelt in seine menschliche Form, man die Dinge, die man, die Eigenschaften, die man durch das Tragen der Ringe erworben hat, dann praktisch Natur gegeben hat, dadurch, dass man die in seiner Monsterform als Nahrung zu sich genommen hat.
Ah, ohne dass man die Ringe tragen muss.
Genau, man hat sie ja dann gegessen.
Aber wo ist der Unterschied, ob man sie nun trägt oder nicht?
Tragen kannst du nur zwei. An der linken Hand und an der rechten Hand eins.
Das heißt, man kann dann mehrere miteinander kombinieren.
Genau, du kannst dann noch, genau. Also das geht in die absurdesten, also mit Polymorphen kann man, man kann auch Gegenstände... Polymorphen, da kann man die verrücktesten Dinge machen. Man kann sich in einen Drachen polymorphen, dann kann man eine Frau, weil man hat als Frau angefangen oder man verwandelt sich in eine, mit einem Amulett auf Change, dann kann man das CID-Kommando auspielen, dann setzt man sich hin, legt ein Ei, dann wartet man eine Weile, dann schlüpft da ein Drache raus, der ist dann zahm als ein Haustier, und man kann das dann beliebig weitertreiben, wenn man einen Sattel hat und reiten kann, kann man das Drachen-Kinn satten, reiten und damit durch die Gegend fliegen. Also du magst, Tim, es geht einiges. Polymorphen ist mächtig, Eierlegen ist möglich. Es geht einiges.
Ja, es geht einiges in NetHack.
Richtig.
Mind blown. Gut, ich glaube, an der Stelle können wir es dann auch erstmal dabei belassen. Wir freuen uns ja auch noch sehr über informierte, kluge weitere Anmerkungen in den Kommentaren. Ich sehe da gerade so einiges kommen, worüber sich erfahrende NetHack-Spieler wahrscheinlich auch gerne austauschen. Tja, Felix, ich sage mal vielen Dank.
Ich bedanke mich auch, Tim.
Das war jetzt auf jeden Fall ein guter Beitrag hier für die 199. Dann haben wir hier bald die 200 auch voll. Ja, und wie immer, vielen Dank auch hier fürs Zuhören. CRE nimmt jetzt gerade mal wieder ein bisschen Fahrt auf im neuen Jahr. Hoffen wir mal, dass es so bleibt. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.